e
committee to order and if you can all
rise and please um follow with the
Pledge of
Allegiance II to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
okay we're going to open up the hearing
on cacr 6 and I recognize the prime
aan good morning uh Mr chair
and wise members of the Judiciary
Committee uh for the record my name is
Keith Ammon I um represent Hillsboro
District 42 which is the towns of New
Boston Mount Veron and
lineboro so I I stand before you as the
prime sponsor of cacr 6 it's a
constitutional amendment that recognizes
the right of individuals to use
computation
resources as a fundamental
right and this might seem like a novel
concept and I I admit that it is um
maybe the first try at something is
something
new so as we're gathered today we're
living in a world where Computing has
become an essential part of our daily
lives from communication and education
to economic opportunities and personal
expression
Computing has revolutionalized the way
we live work and interact with one
indisputable however as our Reliance on
Computing grows so do potential threats
to our ability to access and utilize
those
resources and we've seen instances of
governments and corporations imposing
restrictions on internet use censoring
online content and exploiting personal
data for their own gain
I passed out copies of a of an article
from the website mofo and it stands for
Morrison Foley I
think I just thought that was kind of
funny thank you um and it's it's an
article about an executive order that
President Biden signed in
2023 and this is the precedent that has
been set uh by the federal
level that we need I think to consider
ways to combat and that's what CA cr6 is
do and you you can read the details in
the article I passed out it basically
required the registration of AI models
over a certain level of computation a
certain number of
parameters so it required you to
register uh your
AI uh it was since rescinded
um January 21st this year when President
Trump on his second day he rescinded
that executive order but the the
precedent has been set the challenge has
been
set um that
computation uh computational resources
would need to be registered with the
government so I'm thinking about this
similar to the fundamental right of the
freedom of speech the freedom of
conscience the freedom of the press and
maybe even the Second Amendment because
uh using computation allows you to you
know be more
successful it it enhances your your
thought processes um and I think as time
goes on we're going to see that uh
become more and more true and more and
more essential for our survival and our
Liberty so uh look look at that
executive order the article about the
executive order I urge you to uh to
consider
that so the executive order raised
significant concerns about the potential
for government control over AI
development and deployment it also
sparked debates about the balance
between Innovation and regulation in the
tech industry and as policy makers it's
our responsibility to ensure that any
regulations or laws related to Computing
are fair transparent respectful of
individual
rights and that's why I think it's
essential that we take a proactive step
to protect the rights of of the citizens
in the digital age cacr 6 aims to do
just that by establishing the right to
compute as a fundamental right protected
by the state
constitution I if it were
[Music]
adopted so in
closing I urge you to consider this uh I
urge you to think about it and uh
consider the need the potential need for
this as a as a protected right enshrined
in our
Constitution and with that I'll be happy
to take any
questions questions representative
McFarland thank you representative Ammon
um my first question is with regard to
the wording of the article I notice that
you don't speak to encryption uh what
are your thoughts on a possible
Amendment to the article um that is
proposed here that would
address that as as part of this
right that's a very good question
um because
encryption uh necessarily involves
computation whether you're
doing a math problem on a piece of paper
or using highlevel computation to really
firmly encrypt something I think it's
sort of implied follow up follow up so
while I would tend to agree with you in
my interpretation I imagine that there
would be a lot of other interpretations
do you think that changing the language
in that way would make it less likely to
pause uh I don't know I'd have to see
the language it should be simple clear
and easy to understand because it's
going out to the citizens of New
Hampshire to vote on so that would be my
uh desire is that whatever if you if you
have an amendment that it's simple and
clear thank you representative TR thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking the
question um building on are similar to
um what representative McFarland just
asked I read it's obviously there's only
two sentences to this so when I read the
first sentence the right of individuals
to freely access use and employ
computation
resources including devices and networks
essential to computation shall not be
infringed that to me sounds like it
could interfere with all forms of
security not just encryption but all
sorts of authentication access to
private networks to public networks um I
agree with your basic premise that our
lives are hugely dependent on
computational resources and and
restricting them could have severe
consequences but the language here
worries me I see the next sentence says
discriminatory um but I'm not really
sure how discriminatory would would in
any way limit what the first sentence
says could you say a little bit more
about your thinking there yeah thank
thank you for the question um just like
the freedom of the press right doesn't
it doesn't demand that you have access
to all the presses or be provided a
press right it's it's the ability to
express yourself using you know the
Press was a machine that pressed copy
onto paper right that was what a press
was um the computer is just a more
complicated version of that and you know
a less materialized version of that and
so you know similar to freedom of the
press this would be the freedom to use
computational resources it doesn't mean
that you can impose yourself on other
people's resources and computation with
encryption it
creates barriers that prevent you you
know you'd have to defy the laws of
physics maybe to break encryption to
access some access someone else's
private information
that's protected by encryption so I
think I think the right sort of balances
it representative
Smith thank you very much um I'm a lite
and to me computation is addition
subtraction
multiplication yeah that's the
foundation of it and after that I'm on
very thin
ice but I'm thinking about a number of
bills that we have had this
term that deal with um abuses against
children
and those
bills generate not
just neutral academic response but
certainly emotional response and I
but if I read
this
um if someone has been involved for
example in child
pornography that's a very serious thing
that you're you're bringing
and if there's been an attempt in the
best interests of the people of the
state to
protect the the rest of us
from public from from from this
individual having access to child
pornography you're talking about using
computation in the commission of a crime
a very serious crime in this case but
using abusing a right rights don't have
rights aren't unlimited right and if you
look at the language of the amendment it
covers the scenario that you're
describing help help me see where
representative would you read the the
first sentence for
me freely access use and employ
computation resour
oh devices and networks essential for
conversation shall not be infringed no
law regulation shall impose
discriminatory rat restrictions or
limitations that unreasonably burden
that right
right so unreasonably would be one of
the one of the qualifiers in in that so
just like we have the right we have the
First Amendment right the right to bear
arms but if we go the First Amendment
even
I I do know that um but we don't have a
right to go around shooting people
willy-nilly right that that would be
abusing that right and therefore we
don't deserve it in that case so it
would be the same standard would apply
to this this potential right thank you
okay thank you representative
Horgan yes these Ai and then other U
emerging Technologies I know you're
personally interested in like Bitcoin
and blockchain they use an immense
amount of uh electricity and often the
servers uh there's a lot of
externalities Associated the servers
because they aside from using
electricity they often generate heat and
noise and you know there's been some um
so does the does this interfere with the
States you know you know responsibility
to you know conserve energy and manage
the power grid and just make sure uh the
infrastructure
operates operates fairly for everyone
involved and that you know these AI
servers and whatnot don't like
monopolize the power supply you know to
the you know to the detriment of like
other uses of uh of the power supply
could did you explain that question yes
well we had a lot of problems well
certainly with Bitcoin you know there
was like uh when it came in there a lot
of small uh entrepreneurs who would set
up these Bitcoin centers in various
remote places near hydr power which
would often like create problems for the
neighbors and then on a larger thing
with the AI um you know like Google for
example I think I believe it was uh well
now I forget which um Google or one of
the other like major players for example
is going to reopen The Three Mile Island
nuclear plant and build a huge AI Farm
around it so that's obviously there's a
lot of electricity a lot of power being
used on that and then do in the state of
some responsibility to like uh at least
keep that in check so like that one
particular segment the economy doesn't
crowd out everything else in the economy
and you know use up all the available
energy
Supply I guess I don't have that same
fear that it's going to eat up the whole
economy it seems kind of far-fetched to
be you know just in in my opinion
[Music]
um we're talking about a uh National sec
SEC issue when you talk about AI
building AI D data centers if if our
government slows down the advancement of
AI in this
country do you think China's going to do
the same thing do you think Russia's
going to do the same thing so we're in a
we're in a a very large and fast
competition right now and it has to do
with providing efficient compute and
feeding it with energy and so that these
AI models can be trained and get smarter
and bigger so I I just don't see that
it's going to eat up the economy I think
it's a tool that's very useful uh that
we should encourage China will
definitely do the same thing Russia
seems to be society and declined I'm not
sure but anyway thanks for your answer
all right thank you representative
mayos thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I don't have the
article you were referring to so I'm
wondering if you could um
specify what your concerns were with
President Biden's executive order I
don't have it I don't have what I I
passed out all the copies that I was
able to print okay so I'm just going to
go off of memory um it's the first time
that the government the federal
government demanded that if you're if
you have powerful computation that you
have to register that with the
government you have to regularly report
on it to the government as if as if it's
a dangerous nuclear weapon
that's the way they treated it as if it
was file material that could give us all
radiation poisoning it's it's a computer
it's a big computer but it's the first
time that that's ever happened and so
the precedent has been set um it's true
that it was
rescinded but only because an election
was won right if the if the election
went the other way that that order would
still be in effect today so I think it's
it's incumbent on us as as a state with
our own constitution enshrining rights
into it that we can consider that this
might be a right that we should enshrine
because it's only going to get more
embedded into our way of life like our
expression is only going to it it's
going to be Amplified through
computation more and more and so it
should be considered an extension of our
of our thought process and our our
conscience so in in my view I mean just
presenting this as a as an potential
idea so thank you you have a followup
thank you um I wasn't really I haven't
read the I now have the article but I
haven't read it but could you be a
little more specific about what you were
talking about about you mentioned I
think registering you mentioned two
words registering and something else
that was required regular reporting
regular so it was the Secretary of
Commerce was empowered to
make sure that they had the whole
industry registered so if your AI
compute model was a certain size and
it's in the executive order certain
level of computation certain number of
parameters for your large language model
if it met that threshold then you had to
register your model with the government
and regularly report on your activity
and sort of uh explain yourself you know
on on a certain tricks on what you were
doing how you were training it and all
these other things so it's the first
time it's happened I'm just saying like
it um maybe we want to push back against
that
precedent so thank you do do you think
that might limit or sty people that want
to do this work they might say maybe
I'll stay out of it is it going to limit
our ability to compete if we have to
register these things it potentially
could I mean I don't know if you saw
what Europe is doing and it's like only
in the last day or to they're you know
they're putting a bunch of money towards
AI but they're also completely
micromanaging it right and I think in
that environment it would stifle our
ability to compete and it also
concentrates power into the hands of a
few corporations that have the lawyers
and the technical knowhow right it it
stifles the the startups and the you
know the next potential big idea could
be stifled so representative mcfallen
you had one then thank you thank you Mr
chairman uh would you agree
that for those people who might be
looking at this Constitutional Amendment
and saying why now why in this state why
is this not an issue for somebody else
or an issue at the federal
level that we here in this committee um
received testimony as U representative
Smith was alluding to a week ago on
House Bill
293 um which is is legislation that
intends to prevent minors from accessing
obscenity but actually acts to restrict
people's ability to compute would you
agree that this is a a present issue not
only nationally and internationally but
in this state and that we already have
in the example of um article 2A uh where
there's a broad constitutional uh
protection for the right to keep and
bear arms we still have reasonable
legislation uh and some might even say
overburdensome legislation that has been
upheld by the
courts
uh based on my understanding of what you
just described I do agree with that yeah
thanks representative tur yeah thank you
thanks for taking another question yeah
um so quick read of this of this article
that you handed out it's focused on
registration and Reporting um not
passing judgment on whether that's good
or not um
how does that cross over to the
Constitutional Amendment that you are
proposing which really doesn't seem to
impact the idea of registration and
Reporting but seems to imply a leap to
some form of restriction that I don't
see in this in this uh executive order
or or maybe the flip side why didn't you
target this directly rather than the way
that this this is worded it's a broadly
stated
right um so my question I guess could I
if I could ask you a question in return
if I was developing a large AI model and
I didn't comply with registering it or
reporting on it what would happen to me
and my company and you know my resources
right there's there's always and or else
whenever there's a demand for reporting
and you know registration so that that
would be my response is it's the or else
that we're pushing back against yeah and
again just sorry followup because you
did ask um I think what I what I'm
saying is registration and aggregate
reporting of of your activities I mean
if those are in place not passing
judgment good or not good or bad you
know if that's the law then every
organization has to comply with it um
it's not it was an executive order but
executive order okay yes we were all
familiar with those these days um
the uh you know the leap between between
that versus what this implies which is
that somehow that is going to restrict
this is an individual right not a sort
of collective right it doesn't sort of
say how this would be you know
prosecuted or enforced so I guess that
is not to belabor this but you know how
do you make the leap between a reporting
requirement to you know discriminatory
prevention of access to computer systems
um the gun owner and me would say if I
had to register my guns with the
government I'd probably have a problem
with that right so it's sort of a
similar or if I was if I had a a
printing press and I had to register
that printing press with the government
I'd have a similar reaction right like
you know it's a you know it may not be
overly burdensome but it's still an an
invasion of my right by having to report
on myself to the government right that
that's kind of my gut gut reaction to
that any other questions seeing none
Scott thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee for the opportunity to
testify here today uh my name is Sarah
Scott and I'm the deputy state director
for Americans for Prosperity here in New
Hampshire and on behalf of our activists
across the state we are here in support
of this legislation which seeks to
enshrine the right to compute in the
state's Constitution so we support this
amendment because we believe in the
transformative capability of artificial
intelligence and emerging Technologies
we believe that technology can meet its
fullest potential when the government is
doing its part to get out of the way and
not emerging Technologies in red tape
innovation in Computing art artificial
intelligence and digital Technologies is
advancing rapidly yet there's a growing
concern that overregulation could limit
access to computational resources stifle
Innovation and restrict individual
autonomy in the digital space some
policy makers across the country are
seeking to impose sweeping restrictions
on Computing tools which could hinder
economic growth personal freedoms
Competitive Edge in technology
businesses are watching the landscape
very closely right now and Tech firms
need predictability in the laws that
govern their industry a constitutional
amendment provides the highest level of
protection ensuring these companies and
individuals won't face sudden
restrictive legislation that forces them
to leave the
state in an increasingly Digital World
access to and the ability to utilize
Computing resources are no longer
luxuries but necessities and this
constitutional Amendment recognizes that
the basic access to computation is
essential for participation in modern
society from education to employment uh
to Civic engagement and communication
similar to how we protect the rights to
free speech and assembly we must also
protect the right to compute and ensure
that all individuals have access to
utilize the digital tools they need to
thrive uh this amendment is really just
focused on affirming the fundament Al
principle that individuals should not be
arbitrarily denied access to
computational resources necessary for
full participation in the 21st century
so it's for these reasons that we ask
you to support this amendment happy to
take questions representative foran um I
apologize I was uh taking a phone call
when you you started so what is your
name what's the name of the organization
you're representing and who is that
organization again uh my name is Sarah
Scott and I'm with Americans for
Prosperity America for Prosperity okay
yes I'm familiar with them so I know
where they're okay I get it thanks
representative trip thank you thank you
for taking my question uh since this is
going to uh become a Right does that
mean that the uh like the state of New
Hampshire has to
provide uh the internet access the uh
the uh computers the uh whatever
whatever else is needed for computation
I would view this as similar to some of
the things that uh representative Ammon
brought up like the first amendment for
example we tell people they have a First
Amendment right we don't tell them that
they have a right to access that um same
with the Second Amendment uh I can't
walk into the store and say because I
have a Second Amendment right you have
to give me the gun for free um so I view
this uh in a similar
manner thank you representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman um and
thank you for your testimony so I I
think in a similar fashion to my
question to representative Ammon I would
ask you in your
organization do you believe that the
language of this proposed constitutional
amendment is sufficiently Broad and do
you think it would help or hurt this
legislation to be more explicit around
encryption so I think uh thank you for
the question and I think that when
you're looking at encryption that's
obviously a very complicated issue I
think it's important to address it and I
wouldn't be opposed to adding it to this
legislation but I think that um when an
issue especially a constitutional
amendment becomes too complicated and
technology is moving so quickly right
now that it's increasingly difficult to
keep up and that's for those of us that
are paying attention so when you look at
the average voter I don't know that
they'll have sufficient understanding to
incorporate that into this language but
I do think that it's important to
address so I wouldn't be opposed to it
either
followup that being the case if we
contemplate that this goes forward more
or less as
written and you hypothetically Envision
this being enacted into our
Constitution and then contemplated by
the courts we've seen
fairly coercive and stringent regulation
on other constitutional rights quote
unquote
how do you perceive that we might better
protect this right if we were to enact
it uh just to clarify protect the right
for computation ortion the general right
to compute uh I think as you've seen
with um when we passed the
Constitutional Amendment a few years ago
on digital privacy um the right to
privacy we've seen court cases and
legislation now being proposed to really
solidify that right so I would Envision
probably a similar scenario um
especially with
computation what is happening today is
going to be very different than what's
happening um 6 months to a year from now
and so I don't think we can accurately
predict the extent to which where the
industry is going to move so I think
there will be further legislation that
will likely be
needed but I think what this amendment
does is really
solidify the idea that in New Hampshire
we're a state that you can come in and
we're willing to work with you to figure
out how to best allow you to pursue in
this technology um I think that this
really sets us apart as the beacon for
the movement overall um there are other
states that are looking at similar
legislation to this this year there are
also states that are looking at
regulating it and so I think that New
Hampshire has been at the Forefront of a
lot of these uh arguments in the past
and I think continuing to solidify our
position
as a state that is welcoming to the
industry would be a huge benefit to the
economy here as well thank you any other
questions representative Manos thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um I don't remember the the
term for it but the concept that for
example um Comcast or Xfinity can slow
down your internet connection to be able
to accommodate traffic or for whatever
purpose they're doing that um it seems
to me that as I read this uh proposed
Constitutional Amendment it would
prohibit that and I'm just wondering
whether you have a view on that thank
you for the question I admittedly do not
know enough about how I know Xfinity
does it because I experience it but I
don't know enough about the legalities
around that situation to really speak to
it with this but I can uh try to get an
answer from somebody who would speak to
that you any other questions seeing none
thank
you that's the last pink card I have for
this bill is there anyone else here that
wishes to speak on
it seeing none I'll close the hearing on
cacr
6 and we still have a few minutes here
before the next
enough
e
it's officially 10:15 I'm going to open
the hearing on House Bill 615 and
recognize the prime sponsor
representative Dan Maguire thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee um
I lost my voice the other day from the
political problem of speaking to much so
I'm going to try to be brief um this
bill is a fairly substantial rewrite of
RSA 318b colon 17b otherwise known as
forfeiture of items used in connection
with drug
offenses um I apologize for the length
of the bill part of it is just this
whole section is is lengthy and part of
it is that um this is all about
courtroom procedure and in our
discussions with the Judiciary they like
length they they they like a lot of
specificity and um so that kind of has
um made its way into the bill the goal
of the bill is twofold one is sort of
Greater fairness in these kind of cases
and I'll describe what that these cases
are but also efficiency in the courtroom
process so um what these cases are are
is that they they deal with the
situation where someone is arrested for
um possession or sale of
drugs and um and property is seized
along with the drugs and um and that
property is can be forfeit if it's used
in connection with with selling drugs so
for example somebody's selling drugs out
of their car the car can be forfeited um
as kind of an instrument of of the
crime um more typically it's that's one
typical example but also um somebody's
arrested and and next to them is the
drugs and a bag of cash right so the
cash is often forfeited as kind of the
fruits of the crime and so this um this
section of law deals with um how those
court cases go and um sort of
traditionally or or the way it's written
now the there's there's almost a
separate case involving the property
than the case involving the crime so the
the criminal case um is currently it's
prosecuted typically in Superior Court
um you get a criminal defense attorney
when you're accused of such a crime and
so on um but the but the case against
the property is only a civil case and
it's it's prosecuted by the Attorney
General's office so so often these uh
criminal cases are prosecuted by the
County prosecutor or in case of
Manchester City prosecutor that kind of
thing um and and the the case against
the property against the bag of cash or
the whatever is is a separate case
prosecuted by the Attorney General now
we do already have in law that that the
property is not subject to forfeiture if
the person is not convicted of the crime
but the problem is because these are
separate cases and separate courts
different judges often uh different
prosecutors and and no criminal uh no no
defense attorney provided for Indigent
defendants
um
essentially most of the time these cases
are just um there's no contest right
they're they're they're um uh just
decided by default right so so the
person um doesn't bother to put up a
defense of their property obviously they
have the the normal criminal defense of
themselves um and so what this bill does
is it merges the whole procedure so that
it effectively becomes a single uh
procedure and and the criminal case
would tend to go forward first and then
and then the the uh action against the
property would happen at the end uh
typically and and be kind of a just part
of the penalty part of the of the crime
so assuming someone's convicted of the
crime then the property would be could
would be forfeit or you know and so so
so it it the main thing is that the case
would go into the exact same courtroom
with the same prosecutor with the same
defense attorney it would everybody
would be on on the same page basically
and um so that's the efficiency part
right so so you don't have to have two
cases two judges and and all that kind
of thing and we uh look at it as um this
would be the the the about the property
would just be a very minor sort of thing
at the
end now as far as fairness goes um there
that's
also um having that better procedure
creates more fairness because um the
defense attorney who would be there to
defend the property as well as defending
the um the person accused of the crime
and it and so there would be many fewer
defaults it would simply it would be um
the case that that um the property the
property aspect would be held off till
later the criminal aspect would go first
assuming someone is if someone found
innocent of the crime that would be the
end of it if someone's found guilty um
then that attorney would be there for
another few minutes dealing with the
dealing with the property thing but but
there wouldn't be defaults which are
basically unfair the bill also does a
little bit in terms of um putting in
minimums of property um so if it's if
it's currency the bill puts in a minimum
of
$1,000 um and and a vehicle of $5,000
value so you won't be seizing and trying
to sell cheap really
um stuff
the property that's that's not worth
much basically and
um it
also um increases fairness for uh for
innocent owners so what can often happen
is um you borrow somebody else's car you
borrow your mother's car you borrow your
your wife's car or something like that
and you say I'm going to the grocery
store and then you're arrested in the
parking lot selling drugs or something
like that so so the bill has ways for
the innocent owner who didn't realized
that their car was going to be used in
that way to get their property back in a
in a more expedited way so um the other
thing I handed out by the way so this
Bill had previously gone um this this is
a subject of legislation for long
periods of time and um the one that we
had two years ago uh went to the
criminal justice committee they turned
it into a study I handed you out the um
results of that study um the bill has
changed a little but the main things is
we we remove from that particular
version of the bill um the things that
were most objectionable to law
enforcement and we made it so that
what's left is all courtroom procedure
so this has the bill doesn't change
anything to do with what gets seized how
it gets seized anything to do with law
enforcement um what happens to the funds
that result um all that sort of stuff is
is unchanged from current law um the the
bill itself is all about what happens in
court and I'm happy to take questions
are there any questions representative
Smith
thank you good morning
um in a case in which the accused is
represented by the public
defender it's a criminal
case would under current law and
practice the public defender
also be
permitted to represent the
accused in the issues related
to forfeiture rather than the original
crime yes thank you for the question
representative I'm pretty sure the
answer is no that that the the public
cases representative
Manos I was thank you for um taking my
question I was going to ask the same
question that representative Smith asked
but I'll just broaden it a little bit an
Indigent defendant has a constitutional
right to counil in a criminal case the
Indigent defendant does not or I'll ask
it as a question does the Indigent
defendant um in the Civil for fure case
have either a constitutional or a
statutory right to the appointment of
councel so thank you for the question
but you know realizing I am not an
attorney myself right but but my
understanding of it you know having
dealt with this for a long period of
time is that the answer is no that you
only have a right to attorney if it's a
criminal case not if it's a civil case
and that's one of the problems I mean
that's that's one of the most serious
problems that this bill is trying to
address because in my mind it's not
really a civil case the way we wrote
this bill by the way originally was to
make the entire procedure a criminal
case and and make the forfeiture just
part of the penalty of the criminal case
so one case instead of two the problem
is we met with the Judiciary at length
and their computer
system couldn't handle that it would
would have cost
them a fair amount of money to to make
the changes to their computer system to
make that work so we we ended up sort of
keeping the two
cases um but they worked out a way of
sort of linking those two cases so
there'll still be a civil case but it'll
have sort of different
um different U uh burdens of proof and
things like that that all those kind of
details are in the Bill but there'll be
those cases are linked and it it's it's
um sort of helped the
Judiciary be able to to deal with this
to actually make it more efficient for
them without any cost right without any
serious cost to
them follow up so there would be an
additional cost to the state for the
public defender or councel to represent
the
Indigent uh defendant in both cases
correct yes so yes but so in my opinion
um we're talking about two more minutes
or something like that right I mean you
get to the end of the criminal case and
you say okay he's guilty uh what's
happening to the property uh it's going
to be forfeited you know what I mean
it's it's it's a very short thing it's
not like it's a completely separate case
situation and and all that sort of stuff
um but it's also in less State um um
expense because right
now there's there are people at the
Attorney General's office who all they
do is these kind of um civil cases right
so all they do is this whereas if you if
you combine it with the criminal case
the County Attorney again another two
minutes can deal with both
so representative uh
Alexander thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question my question was
on your proposed amendment um the Third
change uh is regarding um the somebody
else who owns the property but it's used
in a crime
um the language of actual knowledge is
confusing for me I know you define it
but I guess I'm wondering who has to
prove that they had actual knowledge is
it is it the the government or is it the
individual has to prove that they did
not have actual knowledge of the crime
in order to get their property back I
guess I'm wondering like who has that
who bears that responsibility yes thank
you for the question so um you brought
up the amendment so uh let me just just
give you some information about that so
um rep your chairman representative Lynn
um and uh other attorneys who were
helping us with this legislation got
together and and went through this bill
in in a lot of detail and these were the
changes that um representative Lynn
liked and and we and we were happy with
too to try to clarify stuff and um in
this particular
case um so the actual knowledge part is
something that um the court the the
um it's it's the
knowledge they would have to prove about
the the innocent owner the the owner of
the property the owner of the car or
whatever had knowledge that it was going
to be used in the crime um but but the
burden of proof for that is not um we
think too difficult for them to um
process and and there's an attorney here
who will Who will talk to this kind of
level of detail better than I can so yes
thank you and I'm I'm going to defer my
question to an attorney on who has the
burden proof in that specific case thank
you representative
Smith thank
you I'm becoming more and more confused
oh I'm sorry about that no no it's my
fault not yours um if I understood you
correctly you were trying to combine the
criminal and the in quote civil issues
into one
case
yet
the defendant the
accused is to be permitted to have
State appointed legal counsel only for
the criminal not the
civil and if I understood you the
reason that you couldn't handle this in
a
court claimed it did not have the money
to
to help create a system that would be
necessary am I missing something here so
thank you for the question let me let me
try to clarify so um the part about the
court and the
money I'm not inclin to spend money when
it's not necessary right so we worked
out with the court an acceptable version
that didn't require spending money right
so so um that's
that the part about the attorney is the
state could Pro can provide attorneys
for Indigent defendants in civil cases
if they wanted to right I mean but
constitutionally we have to provide
attorneys for people in criminal cases
that are
Indigent but but civil cases we may or
may not it's up to us right just like
any other kind of laws so so this bill
says that in this particular little kind
of of civil case the attorney will
continue you know the attorney who's
been provided for the Criminal part will
continue on the Civil part if you see
what I mean so this is sort of adding
that but it's not something that's
constitutionally required it's it's just
add representative McFarland thank you
Mr chairman um with regard to the
language uh on uh line 23 of the
bill that provides an exemption for
lower value amounts of currency or
Vehicles what what page is that uh page
23 I would be interested to understand
first of all how you arrived at those
numbers and second of all if you would
agree with me that those numbers are
rather
low yes thank you for the question so I
believe that those are are sort of
current
practice uh in this area by the um the
Attorney General's office so this is
just making explicit in law um something
that they're essentially already
doing followup so if I understand
correctly one of the premises for the
the current practice of civil asset
forfeiture in this state and in other
states is to address things such as drug
traffickers and others that are carrying
excessive amounts of currency around uh
that is entirely out with the normal
circumstance whereas when I look at
these numbers I can readily envisage a c
cumstance where a tourist uh or a
traveler May legitimately have well in
excess of $1,000 on their person or in
their vehicle and in their luggage and I
was wondering whether you think it might
be reasonable to amend the bill to
reflect a more appropriate number in
today's society yes thank you for the
question but I think what you're
thinking about is there are plenty of
cases where when the these are just
civil matters
um
unscrupulous um law enforcements in in
other states kind of Target um people
traveling through and you know there's
plenty of cases like that um and don't
even necessarily charge them with a
crime but they just you know charge the
property with the crime right and so but
that's not going to be the case here
right so so the the prosecutor in these
kind of cases in New Hampshire
first of all they have to convict them
of a drug crime right so they're guilty
of the drug crime but they also have to
connect the property with the crime so
um if the defendant can say yeah I cash
my paycheck and that's my
$1,000 well then that's not you know the
the state won't be able to prove that
this money came from trucks right but if
but if um um the undercover cop bought
drugs from the guy and marked the bills
and there are the Bills you know I mean
then it clearly is right so so I'm not
so worried about you know yes it's only
$1,000 but there's some burden of proof
there and and especially the key part is
the person's guilty of the drug crime
thank
you representative tur yeah and actually
my question Builds on what uh
representative McFarland asked and and
you may have partially answered it but I
want to check um that this Clause the
minimum seems to be one of the more
compelling changes in in the bill um I
was going to ask if we have any
statistics on what portion of civil
forfeitures fall below those those
minimums and sort of how much volume
this might take out of of the system but
did I understand that really there is no
answer to that because we don't actually
do that now um yeah thank you for the
question so so the whole business of
reporting and what's going on now needs
a lot of work and the next bill you will
be hearing addresses exactly that so so
this is a good setup for for that bill
um but I would save your questions for
for that thank you any other questions
representative Manos thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question how
does this fit in with the federal
forfeiture law yes thank you for the
question so this does not affect um the
federal law in any way my original
legislation from two years ago would
have um so it's essentially up to law
enforcement and federal prosecutors to
decide whether to prosecute these kind
of cases under federal law or under
state law I mean drugs are a crime
either way right so so um so they make a
decision and it tends to be the bigger
cases or the cases that go across state
boundary of course would be federal
crimes and some of the more minor stuff
and the things that are 100% local would
would tend to be State crimes and but in
general um law enforcement is allowed to
sort of bring the case to whatever
prosecutor they want the federal
prosecutor or or the or the local one
and so um my original Bill tried to
steer some of the more of the cases away
from the federal prosecutor and into
state court because under this
legislation it's my opinion that that
the state procedures are superior to to
the ones in federal court it's it's it
becomes an adjunct to the criminal case
you have to have a criminal conviction
before you can have asset
forfeiture um you have the defendant
Avail the the defense attorney available
all those kind of things make this
situation in State Court fairer than in
federal court but um we
decided because this is a serious
objection from law enforcement they like
the flexibility of of choosing where
where cases get prosecuted and um so we
decided we we remove that from the bill
so the the bill the bill is strictly
about what happens in State Court it
doesn't control in any way uh where the
case goes that's the same process as it
would be
today any other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
Mr chairman my other committee is
meeting so I will leave and come back if
you don't
good morning Erin krian general counsel
for the judicial branch um coming to uh
discuss the engagement that we had with
representative McGuire which was uh
appreciate his great thoroughness on
looking at all aspects of the bill and
and who it affects and one of those
people was us um sometimes cases of
different types are called at the same
time probation violations can be called
at the same time as the new charge but
they they are still tracked by the the
court system in a particular way um it
is not uncommon at all that for a bill
that has a very important policy
objective there is a minor and ancillary
Court implementation concern that is uh
not the primary issue in the bill but
potentially creates difficulties or
costs for us um and we appreciate the
opportunity to talk with representative
McGuire we brought in our ecourt people
we brought in our Superior Court people
um and we think that this is the way
that we can implement the bill without
changing our case tracking system so for
us the bill has likely no cost um you
know we've had it looked at and we
believe we can Implement It ultimately
the policy determination about whether
to pursue it is of course up to the
legislature um but I do want to appear
if anyone has questions about the
Court's ability to implement the bill
okay so is it true and and this is a
pretty lengthy bill is it true that just
it's on it just affects the court
procedure and how it's handled and not
necessarily law enforcement's
involvement in it I would not want to um
speak for law enforcement uh I I see
they are uh present and potentially able
to speak for themselves but in terms of
the court procedures we have the ability
to implement it so for us it is just a
procedural change and and we can make
that change thank you anyone
uh good morning Mr chair members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify this morning uh my name is
Alistair Whitney and I'm legislative
counsel at The Institute for justice uh
The Institute for justice is a nonprofit
public interest law firm that works
around the country in both state houses
and cour houses to protect people's
private property rights and we as part
of this work have worked work to reform
civil asset forfeiture laws
Nationwide um we strongly encourage the
committee to support this bill um this
bill would make uh modest but incredibly
meaningful changes to the Civil asset
forfeiture system uh in this state um
the purpose of this bill is to protect
Property Owners importantly the innocent
and Accord stronger due process rights
um to individuals facing the forfeiture
proed
and also it is important for the
purposes of judicial
economy
um I want to be clear the way that this
bill was designed uh means that civil
asset forfeiture will still remain but
the important part of this bill is that
it brings the Civil asset forfeiture
process in court Under the Umbrella of
the criminal proceedings meaning after a
conviction in Criminal Court the court
uh the state may then seize uh excuse me
uh seek the forfeiture of the property
um uh the defendant's property and we
imagine this to be somewhat of a summary
proceeding at the end of uh trial it can
be done at sentencing or at the Court's
discretion it just needs to be um after
uh the defendant is found guilty
um by doing it this
way the defendant will have the right to
counsel in the Civil for forfeiture
hearing because it is a part of the
underlying criminal prosecution and
trial right now defendants do not have
the right to counsel when they face the
loss of property as a result of their
criminal activity we think that this is
really important we think that a
defendant should have the right to
counsel when they are uh stand to lose
uh property um even if it is connected
to criminal
activity um and moreover it will be
efficient for the courts I think to
handle these cases in this manner right
instead of two courtrooms two judges two
prosecutors possibly two attorneys right
and two cases we're essentially merging
and marrying the Civil forfeiture
um another important part of this bill
is finally is that innocent owners will
have the opportunity to petition the
court and to let put everybody on notice
that they did not have actual knowledge
that their property was being connected
to the alleged criminal activity and
this is one of the most important parts
of the bill because it allows uh the uh
this body to uh fix one of the the
biggest problems that we have with civil
asset forfeiture and that is that it too
often
punishes completely innocent
people imagine Grandma like I think like
representative McGuire said imagine
Grandma lends her grandson her 1996
Saturn Ion it's a beer of a car right
unbeknownst to her grandson is selling
meth out of and using the vehicle to get
around and sell sell meth right the car
is seized because it is connected to an
alleged criminal activity and then it is
subject to forfeiture and Grandma is out
of luck she's out of her car that car
may be only worth $1,000 $1,500 to her
uh or Kelly blook value but to her it
may be worth a lot more it helps her get
to her appointments to work whatever
right under this bill uh that car would
no longer be subject to seizure and
forfeiture and if that car value was a
little bit higher if it was a newer car
then grandma would have a opportunity to
petition the court and to put everybody
on notice that that is um her vehicle
and that she had no actual knowledge
that I was being used in a criminal um
representative
Alexander oh I'm finish first okay oh I
thought he was finished oh I I just have
a few more points I'm happy to take
question now no I'm happy no no I
apologize
um as representative Maguire said and as
been discussed earlier this product this
bill is a product of years and years of
conversations consensus and compromise
and um really uh an attempt to be very
differential to law enforcement's needs
um this is not the C change in law uh
that I think some have made it out to be
um and I want to tell you
why this this bill does not really
affect seizures of property law
enforcement will still be able to seize
property subject of course to that
$5,000 and $1,000 restriction on uh
Automobiles and currency
respectively
um but money found near drugs are no
longer presumptively for forfeitable
currency found your drugs no longer
presumptively for forfeitable that is
one change the other is um uh no I'm
sorry and these are the exceptions to
that so right um no roadside waivers
right so we don't want to see um the
instance and not alleging that it
happens here all the time but we've seen
it in other places where law enforcement
pulls somebody over and they say hey in
exchange for not arresting you you give
me your car and I can let you walk
because I see a bunch of cash in the
back seat and I think that's connected
to drugs we don't want to see that
happen
we will allow the defendant or the
person to give up their property
pursuant to a plea agreement signed on
by the prosecuting Authority and the
state but back to my original point I
think I was getting a little ahead of
myself this will really be Beyond those
exceptions will not prevent law
enforcement seizure of property for all
intents and purposes right so they will
still be able to seize property if it is
suspected to be used uh as evidence in
um if it has any kind of evidentiary
value in other words right um again
subject to some of those exceptions on
the thresholds um and I also want to
point out that while this is a big Bill
yes it really applies as relates to the
forfeiture proceedings to a remarkably
small number of cases but important that
it still applies nonetheless this apply
this applies to drug cases this does not
apply to every case and as to the
forfeiture proceeding um and defendants
involvement in it um this applies to the
even fewer number of cases that actually
go all the way to trial and where trial
results in a criminal conviction we are
talking 1 to 2% of all cases tops and um
relatedly as discussed before it in no
way
affects state law enforcement
involvement with their Federal
counterparts at all so this really only
applies to seizure and forfeiture of
property initiated and prosecuted under
state law which uh my understanding uh
affects High tens of thousands to low
100s of thousands of forfeited property
overall in the
state so this bill is Laden with
exceptions to understand and to nod to
the good work that law enforcement is
doing again police con sees property if
it has evidentiary value for use in a
upcoming uh criminal prosecution uh
subject to the thresholds of course um
the court can order forfeiture of
property in Li of conviction if the
defendant dies or flees the jurisdiction
or is deported and um it allows the
court to order the forfeiture of
substitute property if the defendant
sells it hides it or otherwise
dissipates it um prior to a forfeiture
order I know there's a lot here um I'm
one of the attorneys that I think
representative Maguire was talking about
earlier so I'm happy to answer any
questions that you have and I again
encourage you to support this Bill thank
you so much for your
time okay representative Alexander thank
you um if you if you'll indulge me I
have a few questions if that's okay of
course
um so this bill would expand the the
public defender um the need for a public
defender for civil proceedings in the in
civil forfeiture
cases correct and what it would do again
is that it would require the public
defender to represent the defendant in
that short hearing as a part of
sentencing or another post-trial motion
um or at the Court's discretion post
conviction um and extend that right to
counsel in that very um uh what we
presume to be in most cases a very kind
of summary hearing okay and I I guess I
guess I have a problem with that if
there are
defendants not getting counsel in
criminal cases and then we're extending
it to something else like you know we
had we had a public defender office
testified the other day like you know
they're already like strapped with in
they're they're overburdened with case
load so even the expansion to some sort
of civil case in a limited situation
could do you believe that that could
deny Justice to those in criminal cases
that aren't getting the attention from
the public defender they deserve I I
don't think so I don't know obviously
what the um public defender office was
specifically referencing here of course
in this country in this state you have a
represent you have a right to represent
yourself prosay maybe folks are
exercising that and if folks decide to
do that that's absolutely fine right but
what we are envisioning here with this
is that um it would add very little
workload to the public defender office
to enter to hear to work on this
proceeding after a criminal uh uh a
judgment of guilty or you know is is is
found um by the court and um it can be
done at sentencing so public defenders
already going to show up right if
there's a motion um to or pleading is
filed by the state to initiate the
forfeiture of product uh the property at
that point or in some other post trial
motion we don't think it would add a
whole lot of work um but it is our Point
here that these people are being
Property Owners uh are being deprived of
their right to counsel today and what
representative Maguire said is
absolutely true regarding default
judgment four out of five Property
Owners
Nationwide um can't even show up to the
Civil courtroom to contest the seizure
and forfeiture of their property a
because attorneys are expensive and if
you lose a $1,000 car it doesn't make
sense to hire an attorney for $3,000
just to try to get that car back and
maybe not then you're out of $4,000 also
trying to deal with the legal system on
your own as maybe somebody who is
unsophisticated in the law
is it's that's that's a tolerator I I
guess you just if if I could you just
told me that some people represent
themselves prosay in criminal
proceedings and then you're telling me
that they need a lawyer for to get their
thousand car back but I I would argue
that the absolutely you should not have
to represent yourself prosay in a
criminal proceeding you should be like
you should have a a funded public
defender we absolutely agree but it is
your constitutional right sir yeah that
that that was the only point that I was
making if a person makes that choice
freely and clearly and intelligently
that they want to do that that is their
constitutional right but we absolutely
agree we we want to see people
representative but I'll I'll wait a
little bit repres representative
Smith thank you very
much uh thank you have you had an
opportunity to review um the
representative's amendment and do you
support the language of the amendment uh
thank you for the question yes I have
thank you and if I could just follow up
and I don't want to belabor this point
that representative Al Alexander's
making but um uh when you say that an
individual has the right to proceed
Pro
um I guess
I'm I can't I can't separate that
statement from uh another famous
statement that was made in another
context that both the rich and the poor
have the right to sleep under
bridges um understanding that the rich
aren't going to sleep under bridges and
the rich aren't going to be under
represented
um yet the point that you seem to be
making is we shouldn't worry about that
I'm sorry just to be perfectly clear um
and thank you for the question um not
really no my I think my point was just
tangential relating to what the public
defender's office may or may not have
said relating to why or how people are
not getting represented in court today
again you have a constitutional right as
a criminal defendant to choose whether
or not you take you also have a right to
to counsel but you have a right as a as
a defendant to reject that Council and
to proceed to trial
prosay that is your constitutional right
and uh just to clarify what we are
saying is we would like to see that
right to counsel extended to more
individuals at the end the Civil asset
forfeiture proceeding process because it
is really part of the criminal trial and
conviction in our in our view it is kind
of through a work of legal fiction that
the currently that the process is
technically against the property itself
and not the defendant when obviously the
rights of the defendant are implicated
when you take his or her property so
just just to I and I hope I clarified
okay representative McFarland thank you
Mr chairman I believe you were here for
representative McGuire's testimony and
and his answer to my question
um particularly in light of what you
were just describing around the
hypothetical poor defendant um and I
second representative Smith's comments
in that
regard what is your point of view on
whether it would be meritorious to
increase the $1,000 and $55,000 amounts
that are written in the
Bill thank you for the question um you
know I think uh representative Maguire
arrived at those numbers as not only a
point of compromise but also looking at
some of the data that my Law Firm has
compiled around the country that points
to that the the median value of seizures
in most cases it's not 10 20 $30,000
it's actually quite low um and it varies
from place to place but really typically
what we see is a median value between
$800 worth of property and about uh $5
$1600 at at the high end so this number
I think was uh for policy reasons
designed to protect the most vulnerable
people and the people who likely are not
going to be involved in these you know
they're not drug kingpins if you're
driving around a 1996 Saturn Ion and
have 300 bucks of cash in in your your
passenger
seat any other questions representative
Alexander thank you thank you for taking
my question again so you've read the
amendment representative Smith asked and
um you're in support of it um the the my
question goes back to my previous
question about burden of proof um
from your testimony you indicated that
the burden of proof in order to say that
you do not have actual knowledge of the
crime would be on the innocent person to
prove right uh thank you for the
question no it would be on the state in
that context in the context of the
innocent owner hearing so basically how
this works if if you allow me to explain
the innocent owner comes to court and
says hey Grandma comes to court say hey
that's my car I had no idea my grandson
was using it to s drugs um if the court
accepts that and the state does not wish
to proceed with a forfeiture grandma
gets her car back right uh she can show
the title she can say I was out of town
I had no idea right um if the state says
wait a second I we think maybe Grandma
knew then it would be their burden a on
a preponderance of the evidence uh
standard to show that she had actual
knowledge that the vehicle was in fact
that she knew that the vehicle was in
fact being used to trans transport drugs
um so that is on the state to proove
thank you would grandma have a right to
quote appointed Council under this bill
no I mean you
know we would we would love to see that
but that was one of the compromises that
we had to work out so any other
questions representative Morton so um to
follow up with what uh thank you by the
way and and thank you for the question
here follow up with what representative
Alexander was talking about the last
sentence in this paragraph the state
summarily shall return property such
person um years ago I worked at a car
dealership and somebody came in to take
a test drive and then a few hours later
we were like where'd that guy go he
didn't come back yet and a couple days
later um the Tilton police called us and
said we got your car and uh they could
tell by the the dealer plate and some
other information and um and so it was
used in in a drug crime and I don't know
what extent there was or whatever but it
was about 2 weeks before we received the
car back at the dealership obviously it
was quite obvious that we had no
knowledge of what was the car was being
used for
um so when it says State summarily shall
return property I mean that doesn't
really say like is there a time limit I
mean can they just do it couple weeks
later I mean in that that case it it was
literally like two weeks went by before
we could get the car back thank you for
the question I'm sorry would you mind
directing me to the page and line that
you're referring it's it's on the
amendment on the third paragraph of the
last it says state sarily in this case
it was a town but I guess that would
fall under the same circumstance as
being the
state yeah
so as we understand it um because of the
way that property might be stored um
following a a seizure um we want to give
law enforcement some flexibility to make
sure that they can find the right
property that they can retrieve it and
that they can make sure that it has no
evidentiary value for potential use at
trial um so it's designed without a I I
believe without an explicit timeline to
um afford some flexibility and this was
again a part of the compromise process
we would like to see of course property
return to the innocent owner to you to a
secured interest owner as as soon as
possible as soon as practical right but
um we understand that in in some cases
that may not be possible and we're just
trying to give folks flexibility to get
that property back thank you for the
question any other questions seeing none
thank
good morning chairman members of the
committee uh my name is liutenant Derek
catalo from the Manchester amp Police
Department I currently work in our
special enforcement division which um
handles primarily all our drug
investigations um gang investigations
Firearms investigations um and I
personally deal with pretty not pretty
much all of our Department's drug asset
forfeiture um uh my written statement is
going around I'm not going to read it
verbatim to you I'm just going to hit
some key points um one of which I'd like
to start with is and lastly I'm here on
behalf of the New Hampshire police
Chiefs Association um our position in
law enforcement is that our current bill
is well vetted Fair reasonable has
multiple layers of oversight site um
from the officer's initial decision to
someone like myself a supervisor review
to the Attorney General's office
decision to move forward with the case
and finally to the judicial process
where it plays out um we think it's fair
we think it's reasonable we think it's a
process that works well
um one thing that I would like to point
out is the changes to the current asset
forfeiture were characterized as minimal
um
law enforcement is in complete
disagreement with that we feel the
changes are quite drastic um and I'll go
over our position of what why that is
primarily um one of the issues is the
and it was mentioned I think by
representative Maguire um the change for
the presumption of forfeiture for
currency that is found in proximity to
drugs during investigation so the reason
that that currently exists
is it is extremely difficult to connect
a direct link between cash found and
drug sales um obviously drug dealers
don't provide receipts they're very
careful with their um ledgers and if
they even keep them or um conversations
or communication between themselves and
their customers uh and a large portion
of our seizures OCC occur from street
level interdiction stops which is often
a patrol off officer observing drug
Behavior making a stop having a roadside
investigation seizing a car in a search
warrant discovering large amounts of
cash large amounts of drugs and then
conducting the Civil asset forfeiture
process uh with this change that will be
completely wiped away because it's
almost impossible for us to prove that
specific cash came from drug sales um
the process now is that is a pres there
is a presumption of forfeiture which
means we bring that cash in and the
person can come in and show that I got
that from inheritance I got that from
these are my checks that I cash there's
some documentation um I sold the car
here's the bill of sale they can show
that that cash is from legitimate means
and the cash can be returned to them um
it is written that way because of the
difficulty of proving such uh a thing
even in some of our long-term cases
where we do more in-depth
investigations with undercover officers
um with extensive surveillance
it even then it will be difficult to
prove cash we find in a specific place
is the actual cash directly linked to
the drug crime and the drug sales that
is a major major change um and building
on
that taking into account our neighbors
to the south of Massachusetts their our
set forfeiture law I think should be a
major consideration here so the state of
Massachusetts currently has an asset for
LA La that is fairly similar to ours
where once an officer seizes some money
found in proxim of drugs the person who
it is seized from can come forward and
provide evidence of that is legitimate
money that they got from legitimate
means if this bill passes we will now
have that fli and Massachusetts will
remain the way they are uh and the
reason I point that out is many drug
trafficking organizations that are
operating in our state are based in
Massachusetts so right now there is
essentially a even fiscal risk for them
operating in either one so some will
come up here they'll send we call them
Runners people who drive up they sell
drugs they return to Massachusetts and
that's where their base of operations is
now I obviously cannot tell you that we
will have a massive influx of drug
trafficking organizations changing home
bases here but it is a factor that I
think needs to be seriously considered
with a bill like this because there will
certainly be a less fiscally risky
environment created here and like any
business that is they will look for a
environment that is easier for them to
operate in and I think that's just a
reality of this bill um and I think
that's something law enforcement and
myself and the association has a
responsibility to point out to you that
that is something we think you should
seriously consider um a couple other
things I wanted to mention is I heard
some talk about seizing Grandma's car uh
and I think that is that is
currently certainly not a practice that
we do and if you go on page four line 10
of the current bill it's lined out but
and I think the gentleman before me
pointed it out the state will need to
prove that Verma in this case was a
consenting party to the fonus violation
and had knowledge of it so we're not
taking
people's property that is completely
innocent and not a party to any of these
crimes that just I I just that is not
correct um that doesn't happen and it's
not something that we do uh the other
talk about the amounts so that is
accurate we do not I do not submit
anything below
,000 um but I heard some talk that a
drug kingpin won't be driving around in
a sort of beat up car with a couple
thousand bucks or below that no they
won't but the people that I referenced
earlier they're Runners the people that
they employ to sell their drugs as part
of the organization will they will drive
around and we just had a seizure
recently
of almost a quarter of a kilo of product
with less than $1,000 doll because what
they do is they send them out they do
their sales for the day they come back
they drop it at a either a stash house
or a stash location they pick up more
product they continue their sales so
the fact that $ thousand doll or so is
is the limit doesn't necessarily mean
we're targeting or going after very low
value users that is not the practice
that we use and that's that's kind of I
think where that thousand limit comes
from it might it certainly I could
understand representative Bion that it
seems quite low but that's sort of where
we get the the idea of it is so it can
be fair to sees amounts around $1,000
that's where that comes from um so in
closing I
hope we find that the committee would
find this bill an expedient to legislate
for those reasons um a lot of the talk
about the
uh um legislative portion is a little
bit out of my purview so I can't really
speak to that I will certainly leave
that to you and folks who are more well
versed in that but um I'll be happy to
take any questions representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman so just
to follow up on on what you were saying
at the end there uh and and if we assume
for the sake of discussion that the
limits specified in the bill are
appropriate and it sounds like they're
in line as representative Maguire was
asserting with your current
practice can you explain to me where you
I think just laid out for us that it is
common place for these criminals
presumably being well aware of some of
the limits in question to make a point
of only carrying less than $1,000
uh that that that is their their common
practice and yet you're saying you only
address the over $1,000 circumstance uh
in your current forfeitures how do those
two comport I mean I where wherever we
set that number it sounds to me like
what you're telling us is that the um
that the actors who are not uh who don't
really have Criminal Intent may be
carrying any amount of funds whereas the
the real criminals are going to stay
below that threshold no matter what
so I wouldn't say that it's a practice
for them to carry under that I was just
using that example as that person so the
person that we sees just under a th000
still had a large amount of product on
them so they would have sold well over a
th000 probably into the 2 to 3,000 range
I was just saying in that General range
that's why it's around there because
even though you know it is a fair
assumption for someone who's not
familiar with kind of these
organizations how they practice well
that why would you know a large dealer a
large organization carry so little I
think it's for the exact reason one they
don't want to get robbed and lose a lot
of money they don't want to have law
enforcement stop and lose a lot of money
so setting it where it is I think is a
reasonable amount where we're kind of
putting out the users who might have a
couple hundred bucks on them maybe um
looking to buy a few
grams but keeping it a threshold where
it's those traffickers who use Runners
we can still effectively seize the seize
uh currency from them thank you
representative
rmo you representative rbo yes yeah nope
sorry thank you and thank you for taking
my question um to your comments about
Massachusetts and the concerns about the
impact from drugs in Massachusetts in
New Hampshire um are you aware of or can
you share any information to other
states maybe who have had differences in
their for fiter systems or made changes
in those legislations how that may have
impacted um moving the sort of the drug
trafficking Focus to a neighboring
state I can't I don't um I just
basically going off of our current
situation and a lot of assumptions based
on human behavior I don't have any
specific it wasn't wasn't intended as a
trick question I'm just curious to see
if other states had dealt with that that
shift right no I think it's a very fair
question and uh thanks yeah I would be
curious myself to look into that now
thank you m thank
you any other questions seeing none
Tim MC is it m m
okay
yeah
okay oh one more time there you go okay
thank you committee members for hearing
my testimony
my name is uh Timothy macac I am a
lieutenant with the Nashville Police
Department I've been there for about 21
years now um just as far as a little
background I apologize I didn't have a
handout for everyone uh I can certainly
email that and have it forwarded to you
uh for your review um I I won't belabor
the point I'm to touch on um a lot of
the same points and mostly the the the
more factual points that I was concerned
with in opposition to this bill um that
Lieutenant Cataldo um eloquently spoke
on um was the uh removal of certain
verbiage in the um current statute or
current law that allows for us to um
seize funds that are within proximity to
Controlled
Substances uh while that being a minor
alteration of the verbage that exists in
the current law and changing it to um
what it is now um I can't understate the
point of like what Lieutenant catalo
previously testified to is that often
drug dealers
um uh you know have cash on hand and
have them those those funds call Le in
in their in their business uh it is a
cash business and it's it's quite
profitable um I think if by changing
that verbiage it would allow for um
officers to be to impair their
investigations to seize funds when they
believe it is involved in an
investigation
um when they're uh you know in the
course of an interdiction stop or
long-term investigation if we come
across large um large amounts of cash it
is typical that we would seize it and
and continue our investigation like uh
lieutenant talo stated um we're not
within the um we continue our
investigation even once it's seized um
and we obviously when a defendant or
someone an involved party that could be
caught up in an investigation can offer
proof that their uh the funds that we
seize or the assets we take are believed
to be um not illg gotten and not illicit
we certainly are um can take take that
as part of the investigation and return
items when they are necessary uh we
proceed in the into proceedings when we
don't feel like they are that is
legitimate and that they are ill gotten
gains and illicit means um the reason
why um obviously asset forfeiture has
been established is to take away that
funding mechanism for um drug drug
dealers and make it a less fruitful
Endeavor uh additionally it helps
dismantle these organizations that have
um webs of people working for them and
makes it so that they can't reestablish
easily um by working it through the
current system we have I believe there
checks and balances um for within our
agency we um often when we take assets
we do so with a concerted effort to have
all the facts at hand and and do so and
it it lets it play out through the the
court process and have due process
afforded to the person who we take the
assets from um I'm not aware of any
situation that was kind of slightly
characterized by some of the previous
testimony that um we're taking uh
Grandma's K and trying to take that
without a without a common sense
approach to the matter um I can't think
of a h situation on hand that in my time
at the police department that we've um
someone who's been victimized by our
practice of seizure of assets um
certainly there may be people who
disagree with that but I I certainly can
speak to my own knowledge of the
situation um without belaboring the
point um I do feel that the current uh
while that line item from line 18 to 21
that's been lined out which refer I'm
referring to as the um proximity removal
um that is the uh from my standpoint is
from law enforcement the most
significant change that would affect us
um on a day-to-day basis and how we uh
attack the drug traffickers that do um
work within New Hampshire um the rest of
the the legal proceedings and as far as
the changes I can't speak to the Court's
um capacity or abilities to handle that
and what legally is appropriate but um
obviously that's uh within the your guys
purview to um make those assumptions and
determinations thank you any questions
representative Manos thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
when assets are ultimately
forfeited do you know where the either
the cash or the asset goes where does
know uh typically when we take an asset
we obiously go through the procedure
with the Attorney General's office the
money is held in our evidence until it's
transferred to their custody um if it's
a vehicle say we're we we hold it at our
facility and we maintain uh uh an
OverWatch of it to ensure that it
doesn't diminish it like for instance a
common one would be a vehicle um we
maintain OverWatch of that by our
procedure to ensure that it doesn't
diminish in value um it is a um Vehicles
aren't taken by us generally as a matter
of um ease because typically values the
vehicle values we're we're seizing
aren't of Great Value and they're often
um uh kind of labor intensive to
maintain and um stay with to be have to
keep them current and as a labor uh
Manpower involvement in that to keep our
mechanics from having to start them
regularly check them make sure they're
still um operational so we're not
diminishing that asset because neverita
know we know the court process proceeds
and there's it's not a guarantee or
anything for certain that we will be
getting that asset as a uh as a
seizure followup thank you and thank you
for taking my followup do you know
whether the money ultimately goes back
it goes to the Attorney General's office
apparently but does it ultimately go
back to fund police departments do you
do you
know uh yes the um a portion of the
funds as determined by the Attorney
General's office in the current law will
come back to the police department and
it will go into an asset forfeiture fund
uh at the police
department representative horon um thank
you very much um we we've heard a lot of
talk about Massachusetts and as you know
uh NASA and tinbo Massachusetts are
divided by pretty much an arbitrary line
drawing in the map so are there
suppliers in New Hampshire who are
selling into Massachusetts so is this
just in the context of a regional market
or is it actually like the suppliers are
one side of the state line and the
customers are on the other
so I will say that it is is twofold we
are um we are very close to
Massachusetts and we are very close to
Lawrence Massachusetts which is uh is a
designated Source city of Narcotics um I
would say if not all but most of our
narcotics do come from Lawrence
Massachusetts by or
um it is a combination of dealers coming
into the state to deal and also um local
dealers traveling down to Lawrence
Massachusetts picking up a large
quantity and bringing it back and it's
often um an example provided earlier was
a drug and addiction stop where um a
motor vehicle infraction and a
subsequent investigation unfolds based
upon observations of officers and
investigators and often sometimes when
we come across quantities of cash and
drugs coalescing together in a vehicle
um it is sometimes throw investigations
to be find that these people are are
traveling immediately from um either
Lawrence Massachusetts or going down to
Lawrence Massachusetts to purchase
narcotics or uh return to Nash to
sell thanks any other questions
representative
trip thank you Mr chair U thank you for
taking my question sir uh so if they're
going down to Massachusetts to buy their
product I I would assume that they have
a fairly large amount of money but they
wouldn't have any product at that time
you know how does that work out in your
uh
investigations it could be a variety of
reasons um certain dealers operate in
different ways um some uh some dealers
are they bring down they buy a certain
quantity of a certain drug but they may
have another drug in their possession um
often we're seeing a lot of U Fentanyl
and methamphetamines um in NASA now and
they kind of operate the deals typically
operate within those two two two two
drugs quite a bit um so they they
sometimes their sources are different um
different locations um sometimes they
are uh in the course of them conducting
sales they are traveling returning to
their eventual say home base if you will
so they could go down and pick up a
quantity and be traveling throughout
different locations in Nashville where
um we come across them in our
investigations and they have
qu I don't have any pink cards for that
bills anyone here that wishes to speak
on
it our representative papil
mu thank you very much Mr chair and
members of the committee as a co-sponsor
I just wanted to take a couple of
minutes to quickly go through a couple
of the topics that came up during the
discussion of this bill I I'm going to
try not to repeat anything that was
already said because once is enough um
we had questions about the impact on
public defenders I hope that by now it's
pretty clear how minimal that is I do
not believe that one person who needs a
civil defender in a criminal case would
be unable to obtain it because of the
minimal strain put by including this
civil proceeding at the end of a
criminal case it it is literally a very
very minimal amount of time and effort
that be required and it should not put a
strain on the
system um we've spoken about the fact
that U you know there are minimum
amounts in this bill they are quite low
again in a different state that has
fewer protections we would maybe fight
for more in this case I think the
current levels work fine I just want to
address one significant objection to
this bill from our uh law enforcement uh
testimony which which is the uh change
of presumption for uh you know the for
feature of cash found in drug
investigations where this bill would
allow would would require the you know
we would put the burden on proof on the
prosecutors to approve that look I have
full confidence in the ability of our
law enforcement to prove that you know
the tens of thousands and hundreds of
thousands they are typically
confiscating at the end of long
investigations into drug organizations
or proceeds of criminal activity the
bill still allows for ple bar
that may include keeping the confiscated
property and so on but if this becomes
the sticking point for this committee I
would submit to you that even if you
decide to take
that minor part away of it even though
it's an important part to me and I would
encourage you to keep it the rest of the
bill is absolutely worth an OTP because
it addresses significant burdens and it
will make life easier for the court
system for the prosecutors and for for
the victims and I really appreciate your
time I know it's been a long hearing so
I I want to wrap it
up any
questions seeing thank
you are there any other people that want
to speak on this bill seeing none I'm
going to close the hearing on House Bill
615 and we are at the time to open the
hearing on House Bill
509 and I recognize representative
papichi mu to oh representative Dan magu
to introduce
it thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan Maguire and um I'm from
the town of Epsom and I'd like to
introduce House Bill
509 as we talked about just on the
previous bill um the amount of um
reporting of of asset forfeiture is is
fairly minimal um and uh this bill
adds many specific sort of fields if you
want to think of this as a you know
getting a spreadsheet or a table or
something like that so this this bill
would add um much more detail about each
specific kind of
forfeiture uh what was the value what
was the offense what was
um whether um the
forfeiture is uh going to go to federal
court or state court things like that so
um the the main problem we have had
dealing with this kind of um legislation
is is
information um on exactly what's going
on and because we get sort of summary
kinds of things but we don't get um this
level of detail so um it would be nice I
don't think um I mean the bill has a a
fiscal note that says um that it's going
to be
I don't know it looks like about a half
a person's worth of work but I can't
imagine it's it's anything like that um
you know if somebody who has access to
the court systems um computer system I
think could go through this the the
number of cases here 100 cases or 200
cases or whatever create this sort of
summary
information relatively quickly not not
it's not a halftime job for a for a
person in my opinion and I'm happy to
answer
questions representative Alexander thank
you Mr chair thank you representative
um why is it in the Public's interest to
know this
information well thank you for the
question but when we make
legislation
um we have to know what's going on to to
decide um is is the public interest uh
being satisfied right I mean if we don't
know uh suppose we were to find out for
example that that 90% of the cases
involve cheap cars and and and $2,000
worth of cash
um you know we might think we're we're
sort of over um over enforcing something
or or you know it' be a different
character than than if
most of the cases are
$100,000 and and houses and things like
that right so so we just we want to know
on representative uh Mark Farland thank
you Mr chairman representative Maguire
uh I'm looking at the uh the bill I'm
looking at rows 24 and
25 uh of the
Bell if there there is a forfeiture uh
that meets that the criteria of that
Clause
L um you know it talks about made
without the federal agency's involvement
in the seizure in the seizure and that
seems to me to be a clause that is
subject to an awful lot of
interpretation um could you help me
understand for example if uh a stop was
made by state or local officials and in
the course of the stop they had their
dispatcher make reference to certain
federal
databases um would that then involve
Federal agency's involvement and and
might there be a need to adjust that
language well that's a that thank you
for the question I I guess that's an
interesting interpretation that I hadn't
thought of before but in general I think
what we intended here was was there
active Personnel involved like the FBI
or something like that um rather than uh
database kind of things followup yeah
know and and I I perceived that intent
and I I I am very sympathetic to that
intent I just want to make sure we
structure the language closely enough
that the intent is what is reflected in
statute thank you representative
Rambo thank you uh thank you for taking
my question to the extent this
additional information might
inform some of the concerns that were
treding to be addressed by the prior
bill by HB 615 um in your opinion would
there be benefit
to this sort of reporting Bill uh to try
out the sort of reporting bill in
advance of implementing the changes
contemplated by 615 yes thank you for
the question and I I guess because I
submitted both I submitted the other
vill my my answer is no I I don't want
to wait uh for that and and to tell you
the truth I mean I've been working on
this area and proposing legislation on
it for more than a decade so you know
it's I think it's time to to make
progress we have made some I mean we did
get um in law the the fact that that
criminal forfeiture criminal conviction
is a prerequisite to forfeiture the
problem is the way we have gotten it it
it it doesn't have teeth it doesn't
always happen that way and and so I
think that's an important um goal of the
first piece of legislation thank you
representative Smith thank you um
representative I might have misheard you
um I I thought I heard you refer to the
fact that it would
not uh be a particular burden on the
court system to get this information but
uh
I thought that this was focused on the
Attorney General yes thank you for the
question it's the Attorney General's
office which makes this um this report
but I think the data is is contained in
the the database that's that's of cases
that's maintained by the by the court
system but I think in general
attorneys um have access to that
database I could be wrong about that I
suppose
representative TR yeah thank you and
thanks for taking the question um uh
just a maybe a technical clarification
online to um where it says 120 days
after the close of the fiscal year I'm
wondering if it needs to sort of specify
what what date or what um uh part of
this whole proceeding will trigger it to
fall within a given Year's reporting
basically you know you've got the date
of the crime you've got the date of the
arrest you've got the date of the court
hearing you have potentially date of a
seizure which is at a different time I
wasn't sure if you had an opinion
whether that should be part of
this yes thank you for the question
um
so you're asking about the date of the
there is some ambigu ambiguity in the
sense that um you know it's an ongoing
process as as to what's happening with a
given case right so so a case may be
through seizure and waiting to go to
court at the time you're going to report
on it right and and and I think that's
a that's part of um current reporting as
well I mean it's it's not a new problem
I mean this 120 days is existing law and
so I think um in general the part of
this is you you report on the status of
this particular case right that you can
again you can think of a table with one
line for every case and so the status of
that particular case could be you know
waiting for court and and not yet you
know so so you would fill in on that
table the things that are currently
known right but not things that are
obviously not yet known yeah just one
quote follow up on that um so that's
actually an interesting answer which I
hadn't thought of so this is not
necessarily a single reporting of a
forfeiture a forfeiture could if we
don't clarify what triggers the
reporting requirement could fall into
multiple years of reporting and I worry
that that might degrade the quality of
what we know if if things are sort
of not unique yes thank you for the
question but I I don't really think so
because you could sort the the table and
find the things that are final right and
so um you know and go from there right
data any other questions representative
Manos thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm wondering if
this is data that is already tracked but
not reported or is this data which is
not tracked and if it's not track is it
easily
available thank you yes thank you for
the question no I believe this is data
that exist so so it is tracked um with
the
cases um and and so therefore it
shouldn't
be I don't think there's anything here
that should be very difficult to report
on now the the one place where I I might
have some uh
I would I would sort of temper that that
answer is number 20 so I don't know for
sure that when a case
goes goes Federal right when when it
when a law enforcement decides to take a
case to the federal prosecutor and the
federal prosecutor accepts that case
whether our New Hampshire um database
has that case in it you see what I mean
so that's an area that
might uh sort of require extra reporting
from the law enforcement to the um
attorney general to add to this
report follow up I'll set okay any other
questions for represent McGuire San
thank you thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you Mr chairman I was excited to
congratulate my old seatmate
representative Manion on his temporary
appointment as chair I also got
temporarily appointed as Vice chair well
I'm not congratulating you
representative Alexander but uh it's
always a pleasure to be here today
before house Judiciary ranking member
Smith thank you for having me
I last year last term served on the
house criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee and representative Maguire had
brought forward legislation around civil
forfeiture what we had determined and
what we had found in the conversations
around that legislation is there is this
significant lack of data when it comes
to these procedures these whatever you
want to call them the civil forfeitures
and this legislation I think is an
appropriate change to statute which
would allow us to report this data in a
more comprehensive way uh I think
representative Maguire handled it well I
think representative papichi Mueller
will handle it even better than I could
so I'll just leave it there I was a
former member of the committee uh that
handled legislation that he had proposed
last year and as somebody that wants to
make informed decisions as a legislator
I would think a more comprehensive view
of what uh the Civil forfeiture
procedures are about is uh appropriate
for the legislature to do so thank you
Mr chair for the time and be happy to
take any questions but others could
answer better than I great questions for
representative
wheeler seeing none thank
you um I think I had a pink
card
Whitney it's me again uh Alis Whitney
for the record uh legislative council at
The Institute for justice um I'll keep
it brief we support this bill and we
encourage uh this committee to pass it
um we have looked at the uh data
collected for forfeiture practices in
all 50 states um New Hampshire we simply
don't have much data at all so we think
more transparency is better that would
give this this body uh the general court
the the information and the tools
necessary to make more robust forfeiture
process related reforms and we think
more transparency more information is
always better uh with that I'm happy to
answer any questions that you may have
much any questions representative
McFarland my only question is with
regard to that Clause L again um if we
were to contemplate an amendment to
narrow the uh the language to the
sponsor's intent uh that we heard from
his testimony
earlier do you believe there is any cir
irance that would exceed uh
contemporaneous human involvement by the
federal agency that you would want to
include in there I'm I'm sorry I don't
quite understand the question so so I'm
looking at Claus L and as we were
discussing with uh the questions to
representative Maguire um it seems that
that could be interpreted broadly and it
seems that his intent is to interpret it
uh more narrowly uh only to apply where
the the federal government agency is uh
really directly and and
contemporaneously involved in the arrest
um I I guess I I'll simplify my question
uh is there a a different set of
language that you might suggest for that
that would be better in your
mind thank you for the question um I'd
be happy to propose that language if
that is the intent of uh representative
Maguire and the sponsors um I think the
way that it is written right now I
my interpretation is that it is limited
because of it limits it to Federal
agency involvement and I think that
would because it talks about the seizure
and not the forfeiture um that it is
limited to instances where state and
local authorities might be working with
their Federal counterpart Federal
counterparts in uh drug interdiction
task forces for example thank you
so any other
and uh is it
Daniel oh I didn't even know who it was
I couldn't even see that difficult to
read apologize representative thank you
Mr chair and members of the committee
I'm the one who should apologize for my
terrible handwriting and it's only my
second card field for the day so I
cannot exactly plead exhaustion here um
I just want to briefly as the prime
sponsor on the bill um you know explain
why it was brought up right if you
remember
we had um discussions in previous years
about you know whether changes to the
Civil for feature laws need to be made
in any way and one of the major concerns
again was the lack of data now we do
have the existing you know 6 1 colum 12
Roman numeral one language so we already
have a report but we had a statutory
Committee created last fall that looked
at the for feature civil for feature and
We examined that report in detail and it
really wasn't useful at all for policy
or for transparency because it has very
very limited data that doesn't really
tell you what happened so this is just
an attempt to make the data available
both to the public because you know they
should know what we're are doing and
also to the you know people who make
policy on just more information about
exactly what's going on that would help
us in drive the right policy the burden
is on the Attorney General as it was we
do not change the deadlines so any
concerns about the incomplete cases
really they are already applying to
current law the current report has the
same exact concerns we are not touching
those deadlines in any
way we um we feel that all these data
that we are asking for is already
available I mean if you look at it there
is nothing here that wouldn't be in a
case File even the concern raised over
line 20 on whether the for feure is
sought under federal law local
prosecutors and federal prosecutors have
to be aware of when the case is becoming
Federal because they're talking about
the same property they got to coordinate
so the local prosecutors would know that
the federal agency is coming in and
saying no no no that's my case now you
guys stand down we got it so that data
would be available and would be easily
reported to the attorney general and we
Tred to make this as simple as possible
we actually looked at different states
and we paired down some of the other
requirements that were in other states
because they we felt they were too much
for New Hampshire and for the questions
we were trying to ask and the last thing
I'll say is that how many bills do you
have that really have you know nobody
test testifying against them nobody
signing up in the blue sheet against
them I'm not going to Hazard the guess
on any online comments but I think this
is a very basic Common Sense minimal
expansion of reporting that would bring
Great Value to
everyone any
questions representative tur thanks
thanks for taking the
question I'm going to circle back to the
same question I asked earlier about sort
of establishing a trigger date for when
something gets reported versus what
representative McGuire said which is
essentially any case that could
potentially be in this process would get
reported at any point at which it's in
the process I I I guess I'm wondering
what would your thoughts be on amending
this to to basically trigger this at the
final State when we know sort of what
the state's actual seizure was and the
reason the reason I asked it not to not
to run out the question
is particularly we we have these Clauses
about innocent owners and things like
that you know I could see that person
being reported as the owner at one point
before they've claimed be their
innocence and you know it seems like it
could get very confusing in terms of
what the value of this data would be if
you're not looking at a finalized
settled process at the end so would you
would you be supportive or do you have a
reason why that would not be a good
change thank you for the question I
really appreciate it and I appreciate
your concern on this
um I would obviously I recognize that if
the committee would like to amend the
legislation the committee May amend the
legislation in any way they see fit and
you know that's the perogative of the
committee personally I would support the
language as written and here are the
reasons why first all this data that is
reported is already public data from
court system so if there is any concern
about somebody being you know
temporarily you know named as somebody
who's being prosecuted again that's
public information already also you will
notice that we don't really have names
here we have a criminal case number so
people could go to the courts and find
out that information but this doesn't
say you know Joe Johnson is being
prosecuted he just says case number y y
in this court the other concern that I
would have over only reporting finalized
stuff is that some of these cases can
take a long time to run their way
through court so it would really prevent
us from seeing how much property was
seized in the previous year we may see
two and three years down the road
therefore you know making it harder to
judge and the volume of this the
previous year report has maybe 20 lines
it's not one of those spreadsheet with
thousands and thousands of cases it's
you know a limited number of them so it
should not be difficult at all to again
just filter by hey I want just to see
the finalized cases or I would like to
see everything that was seized
regardless of what the current disposal
was again if I want to look at say that
we are already in May and the 20day has
passed it's May
2025 if we would change the language
then by looking at the May 2025 report I
would not be able to see how much stuff
was seized in 2024 because a good part
of that would still be litigated so
that's really the reason why it is
written this way in the current law and
in our law and you know again up to the
committee thank
you thank you anyone else have any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so much is there anyone else that
wants to speak on House
[Music]
Bill the right here
509 seeing none I'm going to close the
I think there's a public interest in
knowing he won the lottery and um first
of all playing the lottery is uh is
voluntary so if you don't want to run
the risk of winning and having your name
exposed you you can all you're free to
not play but also you can turn a winning
ticket over to a trust or other way or
you know to um you know conceal your
all right we have a few minutes so we're
GNA open up an executive session on
house bow 485 that we heard last week
and I recognize representative Alexander
for a
motion um thank you Mr chair I move on
to
pass second seconded by representative
Smith any discussion on the bill at all
um I just briefly think it's okay to
remain an anonymous if you win the
lottery I actually think that there's
really no public interest in figuring
out who won the lottery and I actually
think there's a lot of drama involved
when you win the lottery so um if I ever
happen to win you won't see me ever
again and I will be off on an island
somewhere else and nobody will know
because I will be anonymous hopefully
thank you but there will be signs
representative Smith you want to speak
on your second thank you aside from my
my strong belief in personal privacy if
you look at the language in this um uh
in this particular bill it is very
specific and there're very clear reasons
why uh privacy might be essential to
protect the well-being of the potential
winner you any other discussion on this
bill representative Oregan well just to
say repeat what I well reiterate what I
said before in the context of the ACT
executive session um if you don't if you
don't want to run the RIS of of winning
and having your name published you're
free not to buy a ticket in the first
place um and which is actually except
occasionally when the power ball gets
very high is actually the economically
optimal strategy and also you can you
can
um you you you can turn the ticket over
to a trust before you uh before you
before you accept the ticket too which
is uh you
know which which if it's a large large
prize is probably not a bad idea anyway
so I think the existing law is uh is
sufficient so um
and I will admit I didn't actually
didn't attend the hearing on this bill
but it's a perennial Bill I've seen many
many bills in the P this this is a bill
that comes up almost every session so
I've always been opposed to it so I'm
I'm going to continue being opposed to
it so okay very very briefly the the
most com compelling reason that I heard
articulated in the hearing on the bill
for disclosing this is to be used as
marketing material for the lottery
itself which I think is uh an easy you
know interest to overcome in the names
of the the anonymity that this bill is
providing thank you any more discussion
on it seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
ready representative Alexander yes
representative trip
yes clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
yes representative Morton yes
representative Smith yes representative
Horgan um
no representative
Manos yes representative tur yes
representative Romo
miss
I yep there's 11 of us okay
n no you got Tom any objections going on
the consent calendar I guess um no I
guess may as well let it go on the
consent calendar but okay and do you
want to write a Minority Report on it oh
actually guess I would like to write one
in which case it has to go on the
regular calendar so yes so just a very
yeah uh uh Mr chair I just want to make
sure that representative haran has in
fact um I know he was not able to be
here for the hearing but to make sure
that he has in fact read read the
details of this particular bill um as
compared with the many previous bills
that he has seen in earlier years before
he commits
to H H have you looked at the bill yes I
have but I guess I I will withdraw my
objection to putting on the consent
calendar so we'll see how we'll see what
happens when it um goes through the
legislative process to see yes so I mean
I I I I I have read the so no objection
to it going on consent no you can put it
you right I'm going to close the
e
Bill 601 if we just want to take a straw
vote um to see who is interested in
yeah oh yeah itl for that if anyone's in
601 that's relative to causes of action
against companies that misstate the
impacts of their business on the
environment
or or make a suggestion um and I don't
know what everybody's lunch plans are
would it be possible for us to come back
from lunch a little earlier if we're
going to do the some Su K caucus um
beforehand
does that others schedules permit that
or
I'm I have a 12:30 okay so pipe dreams
okay and also and also like we have a
3:00 deadline so obviously the chair
appropriately wants at least have some
things there so we meet the deadline for
the house session on the 20th 8 days
from now so that's like so we're in a
bit of a time we're bit we're we're in a
bit of a time crunch if we want to have
lunch
e
I can get my clerk here at least and
people
e
103 so I'm going to reconvene the
Judiciary Committee and open up the
hearing on House Bill 587 and I
recognize the prime sponsor
representative
Matt if you could help me out therey
good afternoon chairman Manion and
members of the committee I'm
representative Matt saborn D Schwaner
from rocket m30 sebr I knew it
introducing HB 587 today allowing
admission of one audio and one party
audio and video recordings and circum
certain circumstances those
circumstances being domestic violence So
currently as the law stands if someone's
in a domestic violence situation if they
were to record their abuser is actually
classified as a felony under the law uh
this would create an exception for that
to allow if someone is recording or is
experiencing the domestic abuse that
they can
um um basically submit that recording as
part of evidence collection to a court
or a police
report and that's actually the I think
the language is pretty simple I didn't
have too too I didn't have too much
testimony today have questions that's it
any questions I know there's a lot of
folks here that also here to testify and
support yep representative McFarland
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
Sab um you you indicate the intent is to
be limited to crimes of domestic
violence yes I don't see that reflected
seven okay thank you for pointing that
out well I guess let me phas it as a
question because I was intending it as a
question do you agree with my my
assertion and do you think that the
language needs to be modified
um if if it's the committee's bill now
and if if the committee believes that
that's the best way to carry out that
intent it could also be used I mean what
what if there's like child abuse
happening too so I mean so
I follow up yeah follow up so I I I
mean without regard to whether it's
domestic violence or not if we just read
the language as as written MH is or
contains evidence of what the person
reasonably believes to be a crime MH
could you explain to us in this
hypothetical where somebody has taken
one of these recordings and is is going
to be submitting it how are they
supposed to have known our priori that
the the recording that they are taking
against the current law uh is in fact
subject to this exemption because how
would they have known prior to the start
of the recording that something would
happen during the course of the
recording
that would be in their estimation of
crime uh it's more emergency situations
no it it says reason reasonably believes
okay so so your your expectation here is
that this is the sort of thing that
would happen once they believe a crime
is already being committed and then they
can start recording yes thank
you thank you for your question any
other questions representative
ter yeah thanks and thanks for the
question um you know the to the bill
seems pretty clear I think it's also on
on the question of the way it's word um
the way I read this it sounds like you
have to provide your recording to law
enforcement um and utilize for the
purpose of Court proceedings I'm feeling
like maybe it should also state that you
can't you utilize that recording for any
other purpose because I could see people
potentially posting that to social media
as well at the same time and that
changes the dynamic pretty cor correct
that thank you thank you for your
contribution
that's any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
sir representative jod
yes I'm Vaguely Familiar
because we have a a long and stored
history thank you chairman Manion um for
the record I'm I'm actually passing
along um testimony that was submitted by
um The Honorable representative Amanda
uh Elizabeth SoDo formerly Amanda
Elizabeth tol uh who was a
representative in this body um did not
run for re-election this year so
something that is very important to her
uh based on her personal experience and
so I wanted to share her testimony with
you
today um thank you chairman Manion for
the record my name is jod n and I
represent the good folks of chesher 4
and Keen I'd like to express my
gratitude to the committee members for
giving me your time and attention today
I wanted to share a little bit about why
I'm enthusiastically supporting this
change to our wiretapping statute um
last year as The Honorable uh chairman
Manion will likely remember from
Criminal the criminal justice committee
days his criminal justice days um we
heard a similar bill or uh I'll be at
one that was too broad in scope um and
ultimately just unpassable at that time
the importance of working on and
crafting bill that would address the
needs of folks experiencing domestic
violence uh was brought up in that
hearing fortunately uh the governor's
Commission on Domestic and Sexual
Violence had been working on appropriate
language uh to accomplish this goal and
this language here is the result of
their hard work in
diligence um since then I've heard from
many Advocates domestic violence
counselors and survivors about how
having this kind of opportunity to
obtain credible evidence of the abuse
against them is crucial to holding
abusers accountable the bottom line as
far as I can see it is that domestic
violence is a crime that the vast
majority of time happens behind closed
doors it is often well hidden and
victims are kept silent in large part
because they fear they will not be
believed no abuser is going to give
permission to be recorded in the act of
their crime and this law as it currently
exists creates one more weapon in their
Arsenal effectively shielding them from
being held accountable for their crimes
or the victim from escaping these
circumstances for these reasons I ask
that you vote OTP on this important well
thought out and desperately needed
exemption to our wir tapping statute
thank you any questions for this
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Pamela kyg and I'm
the public policy specialist at the New
Hampshire Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence um as you might know the
Coalition is the umbrella Organization
for our 12 community- based crisis
centers which provide free and
confidential services to nearly 15,000
survivors of sexual and domestic
violence annually
um I'm here to speak in support of HB
587 which would create an exemption um
in New Hampshire's wire topping statute
um in New Hampshire it is unlawful to
record or disclose the contents of any
electronic or in-person communication
without the consent of all parties as a
state we highly value an individual's
right to privacy however we have heard
countless examples where domestic
violence victims and victims of other
crimes have filmed their abusers or
other folks who are um causing them harm
um committing these egregious acts of
violence against them and they have had
no evidence of abuse um or they do film
them and then they learn that the
recording uh violated the law so
consequently victims end up facing
penalties in the process of seeking
relief New Hampshire is one of only a
few states that require our all parties
to consent to the recording of a
conversation most all party states have
at least some exemptions for when
someone can legally make a recording uh
for example in instances of domestic
violence and crimes involving sexual
assault or abuse of minors um in the
case of emergencies um or other crimes
if someone is being kidnapped abused or
assaulted they should not have to worry
about whether the recording they are
making in a split second decision is
breaking the law as part of the
governor's Commission on domestic
violence sexual assault and stalking the
Coalition has worked alongside experts
across the state to improve our
community's ability to respond to
domestic domc and sexual violence and
strengthen support for victims in the
granite state when Governor sonunu
reestablished the Commission in uh 20122
he directed its members to Monitor and
review proposed legislation one of the
legislative topics that was first
brought to our um attention was our
state's wiretapping law in the impact
that the current statute has in domestic
violence cases um as a small group of us
worked um over the course of several
months um reaching out to different
stakeholders across the state and
vetting possible legislative proposals
the language before you today is um what
we ended up landing on as a group um and
that includes um victim Advocates civil
legal Representatives defense attorneys
members of law enforcement and
prosecutors um and so I think the
biggest thing here is that um Crime
Victims can bring forward evidence of
the abuse and not be penalized for it um
there are a few other folks here that
can speak um to the statutory framework
of our state's wire in law um but I
think what we really want to see is that
it's especially important in cases
involving crimes like domestic violence
where it can be difficult to
sufficiently demonstrate the extent of
abuse and legal proceedings that they
now have this exemption in law um and
then aren't penalized uh for making a
recording um while they were
experiencing abuse um thank you so much
and I hope the committee considers um
voting OTP on this bill and I'm happy to
answer any questions so we had a bill on
criminal justice last year did your
group oppos that we didn't weigh in on
the content of that bill because it was
a different scope um we had explored
whether that could have been an
opportunity to look at this issue um but
I think the committee had uh determine
that it wasn't germine enough to the
underlying intent of the bill um and
that we could maybe bring It Forward in
another legislative term that's my what
I recall yes thank you yeah
representative McFarland thank you Mr
chairman to the extent that the
committee is contemplating amending this
bill as written could you give us some
indications as to uh what your thoughts
are on why it might be uh either a good
or a bad thing to move towards being a
for one party consent State um I yeah I
think uh given uh New Hampshire's strong
support for individual privacy and
personal privacy we um didn't explore a
broadening the statute um that far um so
I'd be happy to connect um with my
colleagues and uh Circle back with you
on that but we specifically recognize
that without an exemption in our current
statute it's um been really challenging
for victims in the state who are
currently facing um prosecution for
trying to present evidence um of abuse
um so we just really wanted to have that
very narrow Focus to start if that helps
thank you thanks any other
you okay all
Reed thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members um I was of two minds
on whether or not to uh
testify uh but I heard a couple of
things that I wanted to make sure to
clarify so I decided to testify but
since I'm up here to clarify those
points um I thought it um prudent to
share my experience and why this would
um be something I'm personally
interested in and might have been
impacted in a in an earlier life when I
was uh 18 in Tennessee I uh got involved
my first major relationship got involved
with a who turned out to be a very very
violent man um I can't I've lost count
of the number of times he was arrested
for uh beating me he hit me with a car
on one occasion he held me captive in um
his apartment for 3 Days on another
occasion when the police finally found
me they found me naked with my half of
my face completely black and they told
me that if I stay that this was the
worst case of domestic violence that
they had ever seen where someone was
still alive and if I stayed the next
time they saw me it would be a
corpse when I went to one of these court
cases um I got I got pulled in because I
defended myself it was the time he hit
me with the car um and he had some
scratch marks on his neck and so I got
arrested and he got arrested and it
became very much a he said she said
situation now Tennessee is a one-party
consent state so if this had happened
back in the days where everybody had a
handy dandy recording device I could
have armed myself with video recording
or audio recording of those three days
or him hitting me with the car or all
you know multitude of things that had
happened those weren't the days that I
that I was existing in at the time but
that is why Tennessee is a One recording
state I'm fortunate that the judge
believed me because she saw the long
history of arrests that he had for this
case it turns out that he had multiple
warrants in other states and um he he
ended up actually killing himself after
salking me for 16 years killing himself
uh the year I got elected to office the
first time so that's the end of that
story but um the judge believed me but I
can only imagine victims because I've
also been in situations where victims
were not believed I can only imagine
victims not being believed and having
their hands tied now the the questions I
wanted to directly address that came up
um the idea is how would a person know
and I think this was basically partially
addressed how would a person know that a
priority whether or not um it would be
legal for them to recording so the the
point is is that they reasonably
believed so even if they didn't catch
the crime it's not illegal as long as
they reasonably believed that it was
going to be a crime um the other piece
of this is that uh make sure to say that
it isn't going to be used for any other
purposes I think that can be clearer but
it is already in the bill which is that
it's has to it's legal so long as it's
provided to law
enforcement so it's not legal in any
other context or for the purposes of a
court proceeding um the only thing I
would clarify I think is what crimes
exactly do you want to capture in this
because I don't necessarily know that
you want to capture every single crime
in this if the argument is this is an
urgent situation where a victim doesn't
have a chance to question whether or not
it's going to be legal and has to whip
out their phone and oh my God this
person is being violent maybe you just
want to capture violent crimes maybe you
just want to do Domestic and Sexual
Violence maybe um it it's really up to
the committee but I would just ask that
you question is it every single crime
that you want to capture in this because
I could foresee people doing kind of an
entrapment type scenario and haha I got
them saying or doing something um it's
just a consideration I'm not saying I'm
opposed necessarily to this language I
just think it's worth it's probably
consideration that needs to be discussed
and that's that's my
testimony thank you anyone have any
questions representative T yeah thanks
and and by the way thanks for sharing
this in this setting um um I just wanted
to follow up on that one point that I
raised earlier which is um I I see what
you're saying I feel like if in the way
it's worded it sort of sounds like if if
you turn it over to law enforcement then
the the recording itself was legal and
that's I guess my concern is that you
know it doesn't say that there's any
other prohibition on what you use it's
just the you were able to record it
because it was turned over to law
enforcement and that was why I was
thinking a
modification might be needed and I I am
open to hearing I I don't want to
restrict someone's ability to share that
with their legal counsel share that with
their family so I'm not sure how to draw
if if we were to modify this how to draw
that line exactly um but I guess my
concern would be not to allow it to be
used in sort of any public setting I
don't know what your thoughts are um I I
agree I I think that if it passed as is
which you have plenty of opportunity to
amend here on the floor in the Senate um
that
the I think most judges would read it as
it's intended as we all know it's
intended to be that that use that
specific use is the only legal use um it
says utilized later in the sentence but
that's specifically to court proceedings
so uh which presumptively that's what
law enforcement would be doing with it
as well however if we're going to amend
it I think it's definitely worth making
sure that that language is as tight and
clean as possible um so so if you're
going to for example talk about well do
we want to capture every single crime in
this then definitely go ahead and fix
that language but I do agree with the
intent that no other use other than used
to prosecute someone who's committed a
violent crime should be um kind of
blessed in
this yeah I'm thinking if we just put
solely for the purpose of Court
proceedings that some might be simple
enough to clean it up but we can we can
uh entertain that any other question for
this witness representative menos thank
you Mr chair thank you um representative
Reed and thank you for sharing your
story um I wanted to ask you about
domestic violence that doesn't rise to
the level of a crime I mean there are
certainly many many instances of
domestic violence that do not are not
actually crimes and so I wanted to ask
you
about um whether this should be broader
than just in the situation of a a
reasonable belief of a
crime thank you thank you for the
question I um while I can generate
examples of things that I would consider
to be domestic abuse though not
necessarily I guess violence things like
I for example and this is I'm very
anecdotally I had a neighbor her name
was Rose um I would walk my dog I could
only talk to Rose through her bedroom
window because her husband kept her
trapped in her bedroom and basically
wouldn't let her leave took away her car
could she couldn't leave the house and
she could only speak to me through her
bedroom window he would not take her to
the doctor because the co-pay $35 was
too expensive um I tried for many many
months to get to convince Rose to leave
she had tried to go to a a shelter and
the women's shelter was full so they
sent her to Salvation Army which was
filled with people that she felt were
scary and she went end up going back to
her husband um
at the end of that she ended up dying
because she didn't get medical care that
she needed because her husband wouldn't
take her so that would be an example of
abuse or potentially violence right um I
can generate those examples if you have
other examples I'm welcome to hear that
that it gets it gets hard to Define some
of that for sure and saying violent
crime makes it easy and it's better than
nothing right it's better than nothing
at all but I would definitely support as
long we could find that language support
good language to that describes domestic
absolutely any other questions seeing
none thank you thank
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee my name is Stephen ERS I'm an
assistant County attorney in Marat
County I've been a prosecutor for over
20 years I was also on the the
subcommittee that that wrote this
language
and one of the things that almost all
attorneys will universally tell you if
you say I feel like I might be getting
involved in some type of court case is
they're going to tell you document
everything write down what's going on
write down when you say when you have
phone calls write down the contents of
those phone calls because really when it
comes to court you're going to want to
be able to recall exactly what happened
explain exactly what happened and
demonstrate to the court that you know
exactly what
happened so now in
2025 pretty much all of us are carrying
a high quality um video camera around
with us at all times or if we don't have
it with us it's generally within like
three or four feet of where we are at
all times so it certainly makes sense
that if you're trying to document what's
going on and you've got this high
quality video camera with you you're
going to use it to document what's going
on so that you can show your attorney
you can show the judge you can show
everybody exactly what
happened the difficulty comes in that
there's a wiretap statute in New
Hampshire and unfortunately the wiretap
statute was written in
1969 and as you can imagine technology
between 1969 and now has changed
dramatically when you look at the wir
statute they they talk about things that
a lot of people now don't even
understand what they mean like when you
talk about the operator of a switchboard
being exempt from the wiretap statute I
mean I'm I'm old enough to remember some
the television shows where you know
there's the operator on the switchboard
plugging in the phone lines and
listening in on telephone calls that's
not illegal under the WAP
statute the difficulty though is that
recording oral
Communications is illegal under the
wiretap statute so it's it's not the
video portion that's the problem it's
the audio associated with the video
recording that's the problem
so the difficulty is that in a lot of
cases um we tell people document
everything that's going on the police
tell people document everything that's
going on and people do that they make
recordings they bring the recordings
into court and the difficulty is that
under the current wiretap statute
there's a question of whether or not um
making those recordings is
legal so we came up with with this
language which would be an exemption to
the wiretap statute
and starting from line three where it
talks about any person except a law
enforcement officer acting in their
official capacity the reason that we we
wrote that language is we started out
with any person could do this and then
we thought well the problem is that's an
exemption that that swallows everything
because we don't want law enforcement to
be able to go out and surreptitiously
record people without warrants you know
like we don't want that so we we put in
any person except law enforcement but
but then we we realize that you know a
law enforcement officer when they're off
duty may be the victim of domestic
violence so that's why we added in that
language any person except a law
enforcement officer acting in their
official capacity can make or possess a
recording when that
recording is provided to a law
enforcement agency and we thought well
if you're making it with the intent to
provide it to law enforcement that's
great and that's why we added that
language well then we heard from a lot
of the the civil attorneys on the
committee and they were saying well what
if we have a victim who is involved in a
civil case but doesn't want to go
forward criminally or is involved in a
divorce case but doesn't want to go
forward criminally which is why we added
in that language or utilized for the
purposes of Court proceedings I can tell
you that we didn't have the discussion
about um if it's exempt under this can
you put it on social media that wasn't a
discussion that the committee had but
certainly I think if you you did write
is exclusively Prov provided to law
enforcement um or utilized for the
purpose of Court proceedings that that
that solves that fear or that
concern the next language line seven
iser contains evidence of what the
person reasonably believes to be a
crime we came out with that language
what the person reasonably believes to
be a crime because we were concerned
that there's a lot of things
colloquially said for example people say
so and so is harassing me or so and so
is stalking me or so and so is
threatening me and those are all crimes
under New Hampshire law harassment
threatening but all those crimes have
elements and we didn't want someone to
have to say well does it actually meet
the elements of the crime we figured
that if a person felt that they were
being reasonably felt like they were
being harassed or threatened in a way
that they felt violated the law they
would be able to record it and we didn't
want it to be a nitpicky thing where
like oh you didn't meet you didn't
completely Meet The Elements of
harassment therefore you don't fit in
this
exception we also um we did start out
with this just being contains or
evidence of what the person reasonably
believes to be domestic
violence but the difficulty is this
certainly comes up in domestic violence
cases but it comes up in other cases as
well and I say that because I had a case
where we had a neighbor dispute these
two neighbors are arguing with each
other and they go to the police and the
police give them the advice that I I
said earlier which is document
everything so one of the neighbors is
walking the property line and he sees
his other neighbor who starts coming
toward him and he takes he's actually
sitting in his car and he takes out his
phone and he's holding it in a way that
the other neighbor can't necessarily see
it and we have a recording of the other
neighbor coming over to his open window
and punching him repeatedly or punching
him through the
window and unfortunately we got a motion
suppress that recording and the judge
granted the motion to suppress under the
current wiretap statute and said
essentially you know it's a shame that I
have to suppress this because the jury
should be able to see this
video this should be part of the trial
but because this runs a foul of the
wiretap statute I I can't let
in
so we felt that we didn't want to limit
this specifically to crimes domestic
violence that if there was a neighbor
dispute if essentially you were walking
down the street and someone came up
behind you yelling I'm going to murder
you you could take out your phone and
start recording that and not run a foul
of the wiretap statute so I would I
would urge you to pass this language um
I'm happy to answer any questions they
may have are there any questions rep
representative McFarland thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your testimony um
context you explained why you
contemplated these particular
exemptions you you will know of course
that the the statute also contains an
exemption for law enforcement officers
uh to make body warn recordings yes if
you know that private citizens in their
vehicles and from time to time on their
persons seek to use those kind of a
video camera and audio recording uh
mechanisms to preserve and document
evidence what's your point of view on
whether there should be an exemption for
either a bodyw warn recording device or
uh a carborn recording
device so normally with a a like a dash
cam there's not an audio outside of the
vehicle
necessarily where the other thing is
when you start looking at the
definitions
in
um the wi tapping
statute oral
communication um is defined as any
verbal communication uttered by a person
who has a reasonable expectation that
the communication is not subject to
interception under circumstances
justifying that
expectation so for example if you pulled
out your phone right now and started
recording me that wouldn't be a crime
because I have no reasonable expectation
that the proceedings right now are not
being subject to intercept in fact the
opposite I know that they're being
broadcast um on on YouTube or whatever
it is
um so with reference to body
cameras I think that the exception that
was put in the wir tab statute for body
warn cameras was just to be extra safe
um law enforcement officers have to be
in uniform wearing bodyw warn cameras
they have to let the person know by
Statute through 105 D2 that they're
being recorded so I don't think you can
necessarily make the argument that I had
no idea I was being recorded by a police
officer who's wearing this obvious
camera on their uniform and telling me
I'm being
recorded um in terms of I don't know
that we necessarily have non-law
Enforcement Officers utilizing body warn
cameras but if a person decided to take
a GoPro and strap it to their chest and
walk around I don't think that's a crime
because if I see a person with a GoPro
on their chest I don't have a reasonable
expectation that I'm not being recorded
at that
point Thank you thank you representative
tur yes thank thank you and thanks for
taking the question I just want to
clarify is it your sort of testimony
that uh this would
be reasonable to expand just all violent
crimes is that is that sort of a a
reasonable modification of this to cover
domestic violence and then any other and
I don't know whether the term violent
crime needs to be defined but that's
really the question I think as it's
written right now it covers all crime
whether it's domestic violence whether
it's vient crime or whether it's just
crime in general because we use in uh
line seven that paragraph
two evidence that of what the person
reasonably believes to be a crime so I
mean I guess theoretically
if if I was in a car with someone who
was speeding or driving in a manner that
I thought was Reckless and I felt that I
wanted to record that surreptitiously
and provide it to the police as evidence
this would cover me under as an
exception okay so so you think it's
already even broader than than violent
crime it really covers all I do I think
it covers all crime and for me
personally I think that's appropriate
because I don't want to start parsing
out what crime you can record and what
crime you can't record representative
Morton thank you chairman thank you for
uh this question um where do uh like
ring or Nest those types of camera
systems or or similar things come into
play because obviously you walk up to a
house you can see it but not necessarily
somebody might have like Vines growing
up or whatever and you don't necessarily
see the camera where does that fall is
that a gray area I I think that is a
gray area again I would go back to that
definition of oral communication I don't
know
that in
2025 I can have a reasonable expectation
that I'm not being subject to intercepts
standing on someone's front porch
because there is such a proliferation of
ring cameras and that type of thing and
it again the difficulty is that the
wiretap statute written in
1969 and a lot of the things within it
aren't
necessarily applic applicable to the
modern world that we live in now and I
can tell you one of the concerns I
personally have is if you yell hey Siri
loud enough half half the phones in the
room click because those phones are
listening into our conversations at all
times L just did yes
so I mean I had I had a conversation
with another attorney in my office we
were talking about this statute and I
said' what what about right now do you
think we're being subject to
interception he's like well absolutely
not
and I yelled hey Siri do I need a rain
coat and my phone goes beep beep no it's
not raining today and I'm like see that
we're being intercepted right now so I I
think that the entire wiretap statute
you know is is due for a 2025 update I
think that's a monumentally large task
though um I can tell you this the
wiretap statute as it exists now is
copied Almost 100% from the federal law
ask for follow up all right Morton you
ask for followup oh representative
trip thank you chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh it's it's interesting that uh when
you read the wiretap law it only had to
deal with audio recordings I believe it
didn't have anything to do with uh uh
video recordings correct does this law
do anything with regards to uh uh
permitting videos to be recorded
and it so it wouldn't affect video at
all because again the wir tap statute is
only audio recordings so I can
theoretically surreptitiously videotape
someone unless they're in like a a
locker room or that type of thing where
you end up with a a violation of privacy
violation
but if I just was videotaping with no
audio you wouldn't run a foul of the
wiretap
statute thank you representative MOS
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm wondering about
um exculpatory evidence and whether this
uh whether this bill would implicitly
create a right on the part of the other
person to the
interaction um to record for purposes of
culpatory uh
would it would create an exception to
record to give to law enforcement for
for the purposes in the
were I guess if I understand your
question you're asking if the person
that we're considering the batterer in
the relationship decid to record and
they provide that recording to law
enforcement I think that would be a
legal recording because they could
certainly make the argument that they
reasonably believed that they're filming
the crime of of perhaps false report or
that type of thing um so I do think that
it would it goes both ways in terms of
everyone
recording representative McFarland
thank you Mr
chairman I was going to ask a different
question which I I'm still interested by
but I I think the more important one
you're asserting that the uh the RSA uh
chapter 578 that we're discussing here
is focused on voice correct and um can
you explain then while I understand that
the oral communication definition in
that chapter aligns with what you're
saying um if I know that the the
definition of
telecommunication is the transfer of any
form of information in whole or in part
through the facilities of communications
common carrier and goes
on does it not in fact cover only Audio
Communications in person in without the
use of a common Communications carrier
but on as soon as you start to involve a
Communications carrier it can extend to
data and video and voice and all manner
of
information so the telecommun
telecommunication part of
this does in fact go beyond does have
it
however if you're intercepting a
telecommunication
that's different than filming something
that's occurring
live so if I'm filming something that's
occurring live I'm not intercepting a
telecommunication if I'm able to you
know somehow get up on a telephone pole
and put some alligator clips on the wire
or you know take these these cell phone
signals and somehow capture them and
pull them in and scramble them and
understand them I'm intercepting a
telecommunication um that's not where we
normally see the wiretap statue being
violated now where we see it being
violated is the acquisition of oral
communication so it's the people talking
that type of thing because the the
telecommunication part really requires a
level of sophistication that we don't
generally see now very quick followup if
I may well
would you agree that if I was simply to
take my cell phone and video record a
zoom that that would include capturing
the video data as part of
telecommunication as as defined
here
I I don't believe it would because I
don't think that you are getting the
information in whole or in part through
the facilities of communications common
car here just like recording a phone
call I don't think is an interception of
a
telecommunication if I hold a tape
recorder up to the phone I think I'm
intercepting an oral
communication whereas I don't think I'm
intercepting at
telecommunication unless I'm taking it
from the common carrier if that Mak
sense thank
you any other questions representative
Morton uh yes so I have a question in
terms of state by state I think
representative Reed mentioned Tennessee
was another state that has already
passed this um how many other states
have passed something like this that I'm
not sure about um I knew that there was
a comment earlier about there's a
majority of states are one party states
in the sense
that I'm being told from the audience 38
states are one party States meaning that
if one person is aware of the recording
then the recording is
legal any other questions representative
TR yeah thanks thanks for taking the
question um I I don't want to over over
specify things in the public hearing but
this question about modifying the uh
bill to make it clear that this should
be used only for the purposes of legal
proceedings the the language that I was
was proposed a few minuts ago as maybe
solely and I'm worried about that
Concept in terms of if someone shares it
with a family member if someone shares
it with their legal councel or if
someone it would you think that pro pro
prohibiting public disclosure or knowing
public disclosure would be a better
approach I just and and we can talk
about language separately but I just was
wondering what your thoughts were and
that is something that we had discussed
in the in the subcommittee is providing
it to your attorney providing it maybe
um
and again we never addressed the concern
of sort of simultaneously posting it on
social media
um that didn't come up so I'm not sure
what would what the best way to to word
that would be
um cuz again we did want to leave it
broad if you reasonably believe you're
the victim of a crime and you're
recording it with the intent to give it
to the police or use it in court we
exception any of questions
representative
trip thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so if I was to make a
video recording of a domestic abuse
situation and I was to mute the audio
would it be against the law to put that
on uh me social
media no law that I'm aware of thank
you any other questions seeing none
thank you thank
suckling I assume the read light means
I'm good to go you're good to go my body
camera is not running just so everyone's
aware um thank you for having me today
um I was totally unprepared for this I
came in for another bill and sat down
and and read this and heard the
testimony and thought I'd thought I'd
chime in so bear with me as I fumble
through this I'm a chief of police in
the town of Alexandria uh we have, 1600
residents and two police officers so I'm
half of the department um when I say
that we're busy we're incredibly busy we
arrest around 10% of the population
every year and um yeah that's about 160
arrests and a lot of them are domestic
violence um I've been through two
policey and I had countless hours of
training on domestic violence and the
relationship between her abuser and
abused uh we're often told that domestic
violence is about power and control and
the relationship between the power and
control and we arrive at a domestic
violence situation and and quite often
they're very complex and they're very
hard to understand when we're there at
the last moment these are very complex
cases for us sometimes sometimes they're
very obvious but to understand the
relationship between an AB abused and
abuser can be very very tricky um
they're often exent we're looking to
deal with this then and there uh rather
than a prolonged investigation because
um uh victims deserve that they deserve
that Justice and potentially it could be
a life-saving arrest uh if we left
without it I would welcome any Tool uh
that we could to help with the
prosecution of domestic violence and
also understanding during our
investigation uh with any kind of
information that we can get uh to to
help with that investigation um I
support this bill um and as law
enforcement we want to get it right
every opportunity that we can we want to
get it right we don't want to arrest the
wrong person this is this is a very
narrow exception to the wide tapping
statute and I think I think I think we
deserve it and I think as law
enforcement we we would benefit from it
greatly uh I'm pretty unprepared but
I'll take any questions if you've got
them seeing none thank you thanks for
having me that's the last pink card I
have for House Bill 587 is there anyone
else that wants to speak on this
bill seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
587 and we're at that time for 593 so
I'm going to open up the hearing on
House Bill
593 and recognize representative Ellen
Reed to introduce the Bill thank you
again Mr chair and thank you once again
honorable members of the committee my
name is Ellen Reed for the record I
represent Rockingham 10 which is New
Market and new Fields this bill concerns
loss of Consortium which is something we
already have in our statute as the
majority of states do have the history
of loss of a Consortium is is honestly
it's creepy it comes out of um hundreds
of years ago in England when the idea
was if you killed a woman's husband
you're denying her monetary benefit but
there was no if you killed a wife you
weren't denying the man anything
monetary but you were denying him
Consortium his consort and so it got
created many years ago hundreds of years
ago as this like right of action
essentially um for men who were losing
their consort however it has been
expanded in this country to um include
certainly the loss of a spouse the
emotional damage you experience when you
lose a spouse um and that's pretty much
Universal across the country uh Most
states include a loss of a child we do
not include the loss of a child in fact
we don't really Define loss of
Consortium at all in in our current loss
of Consortium statute um this bill does
Give a definition I'm happy if the uh
committee wants to rework that
definition but I think it's prudent at
the very least to Define our current
loss of
Consortium um five states at last I knew
as as of last year um extend loss of
Consortium and some capacity some uh
ability to um go after emotional damages
for the loss of a
pet I think the uh obvious argument is
currently in our law and these states
and I should read the states these
states have decided that the current
situation we have in New Hampshire is
not sufficient because in our law right
now if you have a dog or a cat and I
kill your dog or cat either maliciously
or negligently
um the only thing you can go after me
for is the replacement value of that
animal a couple $100 or whatever um you
cannot go after the actual damages that
I have done to you which is denying you
that particular animal your companion I
think we all broadly know that our
animals are worth more than their
replacement value that they are our
specific pets they are members of our
family and we love them and it's a lot
more damaging than just the cost of a
new puppy um if someone were to brutally
kill um our pet so these five states
have seen that as an issue and have
addressed it Illinois Maryland
Connecticut Nevada and Tennessee there's
my home state
again home state leading the way so here
I have uh included this is based on a a
bill PRI uh prior sponsored by The
Honorable Dan Hines who um introduced
this last year um loss of consortial
means the loss of Love companionship
comfort care assistance protection
affection society and moral support of a
spouse or pet the loss of the enjoyment
of sexual relation with a spouse or the
loss of the ability to have children
with a spouse so this would cover a wide
range of damages including like if you
were to maim or permanently disable a
spouse um this is pretty consistent
about uh with how it's used across the
country um but that simply adds
definition to paragraph two which is the
current law that's existing
law then paragraph three uh extends that
so one of the things I included in
paragraph three is the specific covering
of when an animal is killed by an
officer and the reason I had to do that
is because a number of years ago there
was a court case in the state where a
judge it did not go all the way to the
Supreme Court but a judge um had found
that the owners of a dog that had been
killed by an off-duty officer NE
negligently killed by an off-duty
officer officer did not have a right to
uh claim a negligent emotional damage
against that officer and because of that
and because there seems to be a lot of
attention given to law enforcement
officers who have killed people's pets
either um certainly there is a a a
reason to have to do that on occasion
but there's been a lot of attention
given to Law Enforcement Officers
potentially needlessly killing people's
pets and so because of that I have made
sure to explicitly include Law
Enforcement Officers um are not exempt
this so I I think the purpose the intent
here is really obvious to kind of state
that our pets are not simply property
it's not like a vase a table a chair it
it means much more to us than a pet
means much more to us than um than
simple property I realize that last year
and likely this year the opposition
against this bill um is mostly comprised
of a couple different organizations the
first would be breeders and breeding
organizations um they have a direct
financial interest in saying that
animals are only property and not
anything more than property it's very
unfortunate and probably
counterintuitive that they would want to
argue that position but they definitely
want to argue that position um and say
that this is historically the case it's
always been the case that animals are
just property because they know that as
we advance in Animal Welfare laws they
are no longer allowed to necessarily do
whatever they want to animals in the
name of profit whereas if it's property
they are so that is the kind of um
position that that group has or has
argued from you may very well hear that
today the other group of opposition to
this bill last year and I expect again
this year um are insurance companies
which of course um to lose a little bit
if there is more damages in a in a civil
action um if you have uh you're now not
just on the hook for the $200 dog that
you killed but you're on the hook for
maybe $5,000 of emotional damage an
insurance company doesn't want to have
to cover that so that's also a monetary
um motive to oppose this bill I will say
we do this elsewhere where insurance
companies will have to cover things for
example malpractice we have malpractice
laws we don't get rid of our malpractice
just because insurance companies don't
like having to pay so we are we do
enshrine rights of action when people
are being damaged in fact all of civil
case civil action is the purpose of it
is to make someone whole and if we as an
entire Society acknowledge that our
animal simply replacing a replacement
value on an animal does not make the
owner whole because you did lots of
damage to that person by taking away way
and brutally hurting their their animal
then we are not doing the intent of
civil action because we're not allowing
people to be made
whole um I would just end with saying
the sky is not falling if we have this
uh this right of action um that we
extend to pets the previous Bill did
extend it also to Children the
conversation around that got very I
think muddy and confusing and so I did
not do that but it does make sense and I
do support that concept of doing I think
it's 33 other states extend it to
children so having said that it's okay
we can actually reflect our values in
the law and allow people to be made
whole when their pet is killed and I
will be happy to take
questions any questions representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman your
bill uh defines loss of Consortium um
and I think defines it in a different
way than the courts historically have
understood it as part of that definition
it refers to a
pet where is pet defined how how should
it be
defined thank you for the question um so
you raise a good point anytime as you
know uh a word is not defined in statute
the courts go to the Miriam Webster
Third Edition and I would suggest that
that is the definition having said that
that it really becomes an issue
of did your pet tarantula give you the
same emotional benefit that your you
know 18-year-old golden retriever did or
what have you and it becomes subjective
and a lot of court cases end up being
subjective last time this came through
there was discussion on amending it to
include minimums maximums perhaps no
more than $10,000 perhaps no less than
some amount um that would be a prudent
way to go forward to make sure that
people aren't like claiming their
earthworm was you know a loss of
emotional damage you could also go about
trying to define the word pet or strike
the word pet and replace something very
specific dog cat horse whatever maybe I
think you get kind of messy and I think
it's kind of at that point as we
typically do with our intentional
ambiguity and law it's best left to the
the judges at that point but if you have
a good definition I'm happy to hear it I
think the whole intent is to go forward
with saying that animals are are Animal
Companions are worth more than just
replacement value this particular
definition that I'm using here is based
on last year's uh Bill follow up follow
up so you've already indicated that you
have an understanding of some of the
opposition's points of view from the
prior testimony we have in front of us
written testimony from the American
Kennel Club and from the dog owners of
the Granite State and I imagine we'll be
hearing from at least one of those
organizations presently I imagine in
your understanding you you you started
talking about this and I didn't quite
follow what do you what do you perceive
to be their motivation is it the fact
that um the language here doesn't speak
to ownership of the pet or is it
something else oh no I based on um not
just testimony from last year's this
version of this that last year's version
of bill but based on the testimony and
various bills from those organizations
my understanding of their opposition to
the concept in general is that they very
much are invested in the idea that an
animal is only ever property like a
table a chair a car that it has no value
beyond that because that enables them to
um make money without a lot of answering
to what they are afraid of would be
future and welfare legislation and an
example of that is I think we're going
to hear from them what their motivation
sure I'm just answering the
representative's question he was asking
my you some leeway so but interpreting
their motivation as opposed to us
hearing from them directly is I think
that's probably a better I appreciate
the point Mr chair is answering the
representative's question any other
good afternoon thank you Mr chairman
honorable members of the Judiciary
Committee my name is Stacy Ober I am the
New England government relations manager
for the American Kennel Club and you may
or may not know that we are a 140
yearold Animal Welfare organization a
nonprofit Club of clubs uh we're a
recognized expert in K9 Health breeding
training and responsible dog ownership
we have more than 5,000 clubs across the
country including 13 here in New
Hampshire uh that represents hundreds of
dog owners who are passionate about
their dogs um I wanted to acknowledge
that house 593 would expand the
relationship eligible for potential loss
of Consortium damages to include
individuals relationships with their
pets and as you heard from the bill
sponsor this concept was included in
House Bill 1684 last year and rejected
by um this
committee um we know that people do
experience real grief upon the loss of a
pet and AKC established five years ago
an online pet loss group that has more
than 13,000 individual members um
there's little doubt that dogs are held
in exceedingly High esteem throughout
modern American society um but the
American Kennel CL Club is an animal
welfare organization not an animal
rights organization so I wanted to take
a moment and just make the distinction
between the
two there are many organizations that
philosophically their position is to
oppose the use of animals by humans and
advocate for changes in law that would
imply animals have the same legal status
as humans and an example of that would
be not allowing working dogs whether
that be police canine livestock her uh
Guardian dogs therapy dogs that unless a
dog provides its consent it should not
be used in a work as a in a working
function for
instance Animal Welfare organizations
focus on improving the quality of life
for Animals we support the use of
animals such as working dogs uh police
canines our clubs have contri Ed Under
the adopt a k9 cop uh to police dogs to
to New Hampshire towns for instance we
seek to minimize suffering and disease
our K9 Health Foundation has funded more
than $68 million in K-9 Health uh
research that has benefited all dogs and
promoting responsible care proper
housing nutrition for animals and we
have in place a longstanding legal legal
framework that actually supports those
goals
which is why we're concerned about this
particular bill it the legal framework
holds owners accountable for providing
proper housing and nutrition that's why
we it's how our animal cruelty laws are
able to be enforced um and we also use
the legal
term pets as personal property because
if animals are stolen for instance the
legal system allows for the return of
stolen property so those are some
examples as to how the legal framework
has worked um I've submitted written
testimony and uh just wanted to
acknowledge that our concerns in adding
non-economic damages for the loss of a
pet could result in an implied change of
the legal status of of animals that
would in the longterm really create um
unintended but very negative consequen
uh for that and I can elaborate and give
examples if that's helpful to the
committee okay any questions
representative
McFarland
so I I've read through your written
testimony as well as heard what you said
and I I very much appreciate that I I
guess in trying to understand a bit more
about the the negative consequences that
you foresee I certainly uh I look at
this language of this bill and I see a
number of areas of concern but can you
help me understand for example if I
think to a squirrel in New York called
Peanut who was recently murdered uh by
law enforcement do you believe that
there is um justification for there to
be uh a a better cause of action in our
statutes against that kind of an event
and a better course of action for for
the the pets owner uh to to you know
recover damage
I think the law it purposely should
acknowledge when there is emotional
distress and there are tort avenues for
the infliction of emotional distress for
instance um but in terms of loss of
Consortium this particular bill is
equating a pet with the same
relationship as a spouse uh the sponsor
noted for instance that New Hampshire
law does not allow loss of Consortium
even for let's say a child who loses a
parent and so from our vantage point the
ultimate goal of these incremental
changes is to uh create statutory
language that would suggest that pets
are of the same legal status as humans
and uh our concern about that is for
instance um let's say you have a
veterinarian that PR perform surgery on
on your pet and there's an unfortunate
outcome because just like medical care
nothing is uh
absolute in that instance the court were
this to pass would have to come up with
a subjective determination as to the
level of emotional grief that the owner
or family suffered um our concern is
that veterinary medicine would resort to
defensive practices in terms of having
to perform every test or every procedure
for fear of being sued in the event they
misdiagnosed or there's some other uh un
unfortunate outcome for a pet and that
those kinds of lawsuits are an incentive
for attorneys to bring cases forward
that in the long run it could increase
the cost of Veterinary Care um making it
more difficult for people to access
Veterinary Care from an affordable
standpoint and it's another example of
the long-term negative consequence We
Believe including non-economic damages
in the loss of a pet would result in I
hope I hope that's
helpful any other
was there someone else that wanted to
speak on this oh you have your pink card
with you and somebody else turned one in
already yes you can come on up and just
state your name okay I got to locate it
here you'll note that the testimony I'm
handing in has both sides I printed on
both sides and just try to save a little
bit of uh paper
um okay Mr chairman and members of the
Judiciary Committee my name's Nancy
Holmes I'm from New Boston New Hampshire
I'm opposing the changes proposed in HB
593 just for a little background yes I
have been a breeder yes I have been an
Animal Rescuer I've studied animals all
my life and I spent some time five or
six years online is the top animal
expert on a
website um I got looking at this law and
I like to look at the original Law just
to see what I if I can figure out what
its intent was if you look at 5078 law
of Consortium you will see that it only
applies to a h husband or wife and no
other family
member um I believe this is because loss
of Consortium between husbands and wives
lives includes sexual relations and all
common interpretations of the term uh
loss of
Consortium if you look at the I included
a little blip from Corno law school for
an explanation of the loss of Consortium
laws and how they were developed to to
be like this HB 593 includes changes
that equate the loss of a pet to the
loss of a spouse a comparison that
appears to me to be negated by a laws
onal
and believe me I spent some very
uncomfortable hours up here when they
were working on the beastiality laws um
and despite the spo's attempt to remove
a link to sex in their new definition of
Consortium I don't think that's going to
hold however our law covers claims of
children and other close relations for
wrongful death damages they're addressed
under RSA
55612 um because RSA 5 78a does not
apply to them um I included the law so
you can just see it I hate having to
look stuff up so I just threw it in um
and you get down to 3D it says for the
purpose of this paragraph loss of
familial relationship shall include the
loss of comfort Society affection
guidance and companionship of the
deceased and then it gives in a a mass
uh uh amount of award that is possible
the highest amount that's possible as
you can see children would be eligible
to have claims made for them under our
wrongful death laws and I believe
parents are covered there too um in the
uh um under 55612 but not under
50770 some might believe that the
wrongful death statute more closely
equated to the loss of a pet except that
under our laws animals are property and
are not humans or persons
thus I do not believe even the wrongful
death statutes apply to the loss of an
animal no matter how beloved that animal
is and believe me I'm somebody who
really loves their animals um
and I I I've been an animal person my
entire life um so while I understand the
emotional intent of this bill I believe
the bill is
wrong-minded and I think it should be
voted as itl as incompatible with our
current statutes protecting spouse and
children and also with the common legal
definitions of loss of
Consortium um I believe as um I believe
it was Stacy said that our current laws
all are oriented to the fact that
animals are property and we have all
kinds of laws to U make sure they are
cared for properly and that uh and so on
um it just it doesn't make sense to me
to suddenly change them into people in
this bill because that would ruined
everything else we have done um for
Animal Welfare uh causes in this state
so be happy to take any questions I'll
see if I can
answer any
questions seeing none thank you okay
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee uh my name is Angela Ferrari
and I am president of dog owners of the
Granite State we are a nonprofit
organization that was founded in 1991 to
represent the interests of all pet
owners in New Hampshire uh we have a
Vibrant Community from kennel clubs dog
owners breeders and fanciers across the
board um I would like to focus my
testimony I did submit written testimony
but I'm going to inter a bit from it and
focus more on the ownership rights that
were mentioned um during the opening
introduction of today's bill so we feel
that it's crucial to prevent pets from
being included in loss of Consortium
laws because doing so would
fundamentally alter their legal status
setting a dangerous precedent that could
strip away owner rights and create
unintended legal consequences some
examples changing Pets As property
undermines ownership rids under current
law pets are personal property similar
to a car or a home and owners have full
rights uh over their animals including
decisions about their care training and
even euthanasia when necessary by
granting loss of Consortium claims for
pets they are no longer treated as
property but instead as something closer
to a legal person potentially limiting
what owners can do with their own
animals this shift could open the door
to government overreach where lawmakers
or courts could dictate how to care for
sell or even breed your own animals loss
of Consortium expands legal standing so
we want to ask the question who can sue
if pets are granted loss of Consortium
protections who has the right to sue
could a shelter a previous owner or even
an activist group claim a legal interest
in your pet's well-being this could lead
to Legal battles over custody
decision-making rights and even
restrictions to pet ownership similar to
child custody cases
uh it also creates a pathway for pet
guardianship over ownership so animal
rights activists have long pushed for
replacing pet owner with pet Guardian in
legal definitions in loss of Consortium
applies to pets it moves us closer to a
system where pets have legal standing
meaning courts not owners could have a
say in their care this could eventually
mean you would no longer own your pet
but instead manage them under state or
federal regulations reducing your rights
we feel it opens the door to frivolous
lawsuits allowing emotional damages for
pets could flood the legal system with
expensive subjective claims if someone
accidentally harms a pet whether a
veterinarian or a groomer as mentioned
in Miss ober's uh testimony from the AKC
they could face massive lawsuits for
emotional distress businesses
municipalities and individuals would
face enormous liability risks
potentially leading to higher costs for
veterinary care and even home insurance
um also want to mention the slippery
slope and what comes next from this type
of law if pets get legal rights to loss
of Consortium what could follow could
service animals farm animals or E even
AI companionship devices or heirlooms
from your family members gain similar
legal recognition would animal activists
then push for restrictions on pet
breeding training or even ownership
itself this sets aess ident that could
erode human rights over property and
blur the line between pets and legal
persons uh protecting owner's rights
means keeping Pets As property so we
would ask that you would uh itl HB 539
and I would answer any questions any
questions seeing none thank you thank
yep hi um my my name is Shauna silver
and I requested this pill at the wrong
after the wrongful death of our dog
Daisy I've since started therapy after
watching her suffer and I'm also working
on filing a vet board complaint as
mentioned before there are five states
that have adopted modest laws that
provide some level of Damages Beyond
market value like emotional distress and
loss of companionship Illinois and
Tennessee specifically allowing consort
for pet loss New York also recently
introduced a bill for pay time off in
the event of your pets illness injury or
death these states are recognizing the
bond emotional dependency Mobility
assistance companionship and love that
our pets bring into our lives and the
loss of it for many elderly or disabled
people like myself this is just
Amplified because sometimes this is like
the only socialization that you get on a
day-to-day basis especially if you're
confined to your home Virginia courts
have recognized the bond between humans
and pets similar to one of a parent and
a child and that the loss can be equal
to the loss of a human family member
compar comparing a living being with the
intelligence of up to a three-year-old
to a random piece of property is
outdated as millions of people consider
them family Consortium does not give
legal rights to animals but asks the
state and the law to recognize the
importance reality and the bond of and
the health benefits that the animal gave
to that human and to recognize a new
action for the wrongful killing of that
pet allowing animal Consortium
transforms their status into living
property giving owners cause of action
and recognizing the harm caused to the
owner mentally emotionally and
physically I'll use myself as an example
I have ongoing panic attacks and I've
lost 15 pounds since her death if New
Hampshire allowed Consortium there's no
guarantee that the judge would still
award it it's just giving people the
option to ask for it on Tennessee law
review.org animal Consortium it goes
into detail on how uh Consortium has
expanded when it first started and women
were also legally viewed as property but
now allowed Consortium and it expanded
again allowing other family members and
now pets to be covered under the
Consortium umbrella uh the document also
goes into detail on a scientific study
called bulb's attachment Theory proving
that the human to animal bond is just as
significant as a human to human Bond and
it gives many examples of this it also
goes into in-depth detail of all the
positive health benefits of the human
Companion Animal Bond um laws change all
the time people weren't able to list
their pets as a beneficiary on their
estate or trust before 1990 and now you
can and as of 2016 32 states now allow
animals to be included in protective
orders New Hampshire is also starting to
recognize pets as living beings versus
property like in family law they rule
for the best interest of the pet and
during states of emergency you can now
bring your pet to emergency emergency
shelters uh I hope the state of New
Hampshire will join these states and
show compass for the owners whose pets
were wrongfully killed as they were also
the victim of trauma and mental anguish
especially in cases involving
professionals who fail to uphold the
standard duty of care like in Daisy's
case I hope that New Hampshire can come
to a fair compromise on this bill like
how other states allow non-economic
damages Andor consorta but also have a
maximum limit on what you can claim and
other restrictions um so people can't
abuse it and um I do know that the AKC
you know opposed it um because of they
were worried about the safety and
insurance going up but I think that this
bill would actually limit incidents and
wrongful deaths because um with a higher
consequence hanging above the
professionals heads they would pay more
attention and less incidents would occur
like with driving if you're a safer
driver you're going to have lower
insurance and you know animal hospitals
already have liability insurance so that
would most likely cover this and
especially if you put a limit on how
much people people could ask for and
upselling exploratory testing before
diagnostic testing is being seen more
and more according to the medical expert
witness that I spoke with regarding
Daisy's situation and this along with a
vet tech going against vet's orders uh
and withholding her medicine later to
call it in and still never do it um
incidents like this are currently
hurting animals medical issues that
could easily be identified and treated
are being overlooked this is hurting
animals um I would like New Hampshire to
please look into the states that do
allow this and see that
liability and um is not going up and
animals are not getting hurt because of
this uh because of the restrictions and
because it would be up to the judge's
discretion and
um yeah I'm not really so sure about why
the AKC thinks that this would be
harmful when according to the Humane
Society they actually opposed A lot of
bills that were targeted at Protec
animals like stopping puppy mills and
animal fighting and again this law would
be aimed at the human and the loss of
that relationship thank you um is there
any questions any questions at all
saying none thank you and do you have
some written testimony that you want to
turn in or um yeah okay if you even if
it's one we can give to the clerk okay
if you want to thank you yeah I don't
have any more pink cards for this bill
is there any else that wants to speak on
okay I'm going to close the hearing on
House Bill
593 and we have six minutes before the
next
one
e
okay good afternoon thank you CH Mr
chairman thank you to this committee um
this is very exciting this is my first
bill so I'm really thrilled to be
here um so HB 462 is a bill that I filed
after learning about um a situation in
my town I represent Mar County 8 which
is um the towns of hen
Bradford and Warner so um someone in a
neighborhood had um talked to hen is a
small town everyone knows everybody and
um someone had complained about their
neighbor putting a camera directly on
their property line and and watching
their um their backyard and they have a
a daughter who's the same age as a
Teenage late teenage daughter and they
have a pool it was just really
uncomfortable and
um I I reached out to them because I was
going to learn more and as I did I asked
them if they went to um the police in
our town and they said they did and that
the police said there was nothing they
could do about it and um I went to the
home and I wanted to see it for myself
and see how it was put in um and that's
why I have this diagram for you so I'm
just giving you the backstory of how
this came to be so the camera is very
far away from the second house it's on a
post a wooden post right on the property
line looking right into the backyard so
I was surprised that the police couldn't
do anything about it and I met with our
police chief his name is Chief Matt
French and he concurred that there was
nothing that they could do it wasn't
violating any laws because it was on
their own property so I did some
research and found some similar laws
that have a cause of action um option
from other states New York state was
another one a close one and I went back
and talked to our chief and he thought
it was a great idea to submit this bill
so um if you look at the online support
of this bill um Chief Matt French did
support it and also our Senator Dan Enis
gave support and I did talk to him about
it so I was grateful for him to sign on
as a
co-sponsor um so yeah this will help
give folks an option whereas now they
have no option to deal with some sort of
perceived violation of someone videoing
them directly in their backyard it's
specifically backyard is in the language
so and that's all I have to say and if
any
questions any questions
repur thanks and thanks for the question
I was it was specifically the inclusion
of backyard that I was was wondering
about um and and I guess good segue from
our last conversation but you know we we
now have cell phone cameras that can you
know zoom in 20x you know
uh wouldn't it would it be sort of any
recording of your home by somebody I
mean you could zoom in on someone's
window and watch everything that's going
on if you have access to the front of
the house I guess is my question so that
that actually zooming into someone's
window is actually covered under 644 RSA
644 um so and then it it's specific to
the backyard because people do perceive
their backyard to be their space to have
Recreation and hang out in their pool do
the different things everyone has ring
cameras nowadays so that sort of takes
care of the front you can't really um
try to regulate that um but the backyard
and this you know I gave my diagram just
to show how this is a pretty rural area
so there's no other houses around so
there's really no need for someone to
put a camera directly facing into
someone's yard um if other other than to
harass them or make them feel
uncomfortable so they they did try to
talk to these neighbors themselves
directly and the neighbors said too bad
we're not breaking the law we can do
so representative
rbo thank you and thank you for taking
my question um I noticed the language
that refers to installing or fixing a
video Imaging device
um I imagine that was distinct from
someone standing at that property line
filming can you tell us a little more
about that that difference or why
choosing need to phrase it this way um I
just actually used that language from
other bills that I had come across from
other states and it I didn't know if
there was a re like was specific reason
for no because I don't think you're
going to have someone standing outside
for extented periods of time just
videoing in someone's home and someone's
backyard putting a post there and so
that's always going and you can view
from your home from the comfort of your
laptop back home is I think more
invasive I'm glad you haven't lost your
faith yet but okay all right I'm just
curious if there was a reason for that
language thank you okay representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman can you
explain why if you believe in this bill
you also think it's appropriate for us
to still permit law enforcement to use
these mechanisms to threaten the person
or property of another person or harass
annoy and alarm another person I don't
necessarily concur that if law
enforcement are involved in some sort of
surveillance that that is to purposely
harass them or annoy them or cause harm
to them
so I think police do need to have the
ability to do that under C circumstances
if they perceive um illegal activity and
whatnot going on so this is really for
civil civil things follow up quickly
unless you're going to so if that's the
case then can you explain how in the
case of non-law enforcement you would
is well it wouldn't be up to me to to
assess it would be up to the courts to
assess if someone feels that someone is
watching them via camera as in this
scenario um and then they talked to
their neighbor and their neighbor said
too bad then now current state they
don't have any recourse in the new state
they would have the ability to bring
their case forward to a judge in a civil
claim and let the judge decide if they
were being harassed representative
Smith oh thank you Mr my question was uh
the same as
representative mcfar and the question
of of being able to assess motive on the
part of somebody of somebody else
um could it not be a bird watcher who
wants to have a camera in an open area
where there's also
water just to see what birds I suppose
but they could have put their camera at
an angle along the property line if they
wanted to watch wildlife and Birds
versus pointing directly into the
backyard at the pool thank you
yeah representative
trip thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question uh I got more than
one but uh let's start with the first
one uh the uh the camera I presume that
it's mounted on the house number two's
property no it's in the diagram it's
mounted on a post down by the what yeah
but the the house number two's property
extends to behind the house number one
correct so it's mounted on the uh house
number two's property it's on their
property I thought you meant it on their
home no it's on their property correct
on a post on their
property follow up corly y uh so the the
the issue at hand is that uh the uh the
camera is used to video the rear of the
house number
one correct that's what's happening
yes one
more one more go ahead okay so I think
you're getting somewhere here what I
think you're getting somewhere so so the
uh has house number one given any
thought to mounting a flood light
pointed at the uh the video camera so
this is a very this is not exactly to
scale but this is a rural area these are
very large
guards so for them to inst expend money
to put in either we talked about a fence
I said why don't if you put up a fence
or a another post with a light that's
still expense they have to run electric
through a long distance to get it out
there it's not a practical thing to try
to block that camera that way yeah
representative
Morton would would this thank you um
would this have anything to do with
drones
um I don't know if it would apply to
drones it's um I suppose if
the video video Imaging
device installs are fixes so yeah it's
different yeah I don't think Rees the
drones
yeah representative MOS thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question do you happen to know as you
learned about this situation was the
post that the camera is is mounted on
was the post put there on purpose to
mount the camera to correct it hadn't
been there um so this place this land
where House 2 is was vacant it it was a
lot for sale for a long time and no
houses were there and it was purchased a
house was
built then the post was put up with the
camera so they were done simultaneously
the the post was installed for the
purpose of holding the camera mounting
the camera yes yes thank you any other
questions represent T yeah sorry another
another specifics of language but thanks
for your earlier answer on the on the
term backyard um I noticed it says
images of the recreational activities um
and it also specifies a joining property
both of those seem like they kind of
provide workarounds for this um in terms
of what the activity actually is and
what if you're what if it's not a
joining what if there's a what if you're
going across you know the another piece
of property before you before you're
doing the same exact thing you know like
a zoom camera two two properties away
but you've got a clear line of sight so
those two questions just in terms of why
those two terms are in in the bill a
recreational and a joining I think we'd
have to ask OS because they helped with
the
[Laughter]
language is there is there follow up I'm
sorry is is there a reason why you would
think those words are needed in this
vill I'm not sure I'm not an attorney so
I don't know I I they recommended it
they put it in so
yeah representative McFarland was this
the only video camera on the property of
yes any other
questions seeing none thank you
congratulations for getting through your
first one thank you
representative
Reed thank you once again and for the
final time today Mr chair and honorable
members again my name is Ellen Reed and
I still represent rocking Hampton New
Market and newfields um I just generally
want to affirm my support as a
co-sponsor of this bill um I don't know
the particulars have not been to my
colleagues district and her constituent
home to observe in person the situation
however all of our law just not just in
the state but federal law um scotus
interpretation of law um including even
things like medical law everything goes
back to privacy being a reasonable
expectation of privacy do you have a
reasonable expectation of privacy if you
have a reasonable expectation of privacy
and not to bring into in into the
conversation the bill two bills ago on
recording instances of domestic violence
but if that's happening in public on the
street you don't need anybody's
permission because there's no reasonable
expectation of privacy you can take a
video of something happening in the
street we see that all the time on Tik
Tok or what have you but if it's in an
area like in a room your bedroom between
two people now you need that two-party
consent right now it's a reasonable
expectation of privacy and you need
consent and the question is do we as a
society think that our backyards not the
front yards that are exposed to the
public Street
but the backyards do they have a
reasonable expectation of privacy I
think we all kind of agree they do we
have a reasonable expectation of privacy
behind our property where that you can't
see from the street and so now this this
particular Bill does not make it
illegal to record but it provides a
private right of action for someone
who's doing it to harass or to spy on
their neighbor and I think we all know
that that's problematic Behavior
um so that's kind of there was another
question that got raised but I didn't
manage to write it down before I forgot
it so I'm I'm happy to um answer
questions but I just wanted to remind us
remind everybody that this is kind of
what we've agreed on over case law as a
society um both in the state and
federally and also we recently cared so
much about that privacy that the state
of New Hampshire passed a constitutional
amendment um reaffirming our privacy
representative
trip uh thank you for taking my question
do you uh is it safe to presume that the
the video camera that is installed is
capable of uh recording audio yes I was
kind of going to go down that rabbit
hole so then the question becomes that's
a zero party consent video right because
the person recording isn't even part of
that conversation they're recording
other conversations that other people
buying actually wiretapping I believe
wiretapping so apologies you are the
Judiciary Committee and I stand
corrected representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman how
large of a rear end does the parcel need
to have before there's an expectation of
that um so again we I I kind of touched
on this on the last um Bill where
we have intentional ambiguity in
language in in in law because we cannot
you know predict every single case that
could possibly happen that's why we have
the courts to say yes this fell under
this um this intent this legislative
intent no this didn't fall under that
legislative intent that's why we have
the judges making those determinations
if the committee wanted to say for it's
any area that is not visible from the
street
then you could do that or you could come
up with some other definition or some
like you know um footage or whatever but
I think the the the thing that's
important here is that we all have a
sense that there are parts of our
property that are not viewable from the
street by the public that we should have
a right to expectation or expectation to
privacy on to privacy and um and
therefore people should not be SP I'm
sorry wiretapping spying on us
thank you any other questions seeing
representative thank you Mr chair
honorable
committee I I like the premise behind
this bill and I'm reluctant to say that
I'm supporting it without certain
amendments because of of further
implications and the first one is um I
want to caution intent versus innocuous
viewing um so like my house has a
staggered backyard and I have a rear
camera my tenants have a dog that they
let out you know on my property Etc but
based on the shape of my yard I have an
innocuous viewing of my neighbor's
backyard now I'm not pointed that way
they're just offset so I like motion
detector will tell me when they're
walking their dog um that's not spying
on them that is overwatching my backyard
and just by virtue of where their house
is located I catch a portion of theirs
so if this isn't worded very carefully
to establish intent very smartly um I
could be committing a crime just by
overviewing my backyard because of the
shape of the Lots the second concern
that I have is uh on lines 12 and 13
Provisions shall not apply any law
enforcement Personnel engaged in conduct
of their authorized
duties law enforcement warrants are
already covered under a code of law and
the law enforcement warrant would not
give law enforcement the right to
subpoena my camera as a neighbor without
you know it's it's like you get into a
right to privacy with the neighbors if
law enforcement thinks that they can
start pulling neighbors cameras um or
that they can do surveillance for my
property I've actually told um I've told
a local inspector to get off my property
because they parked in my yard watching
construction next door because they
wanted to catch them doing something and
and I don't consent you using my
property to spy on my neighbors so I I
think that 11 and 12 um those lines
would need to be struck from this
entirely because there's already
codified into law what law enforcement
has the right to do with
warrants so that's that's my thoughts on
this situation thank you for your time
any
questions seeing none thank
you that's the last card I have for
House Bill 462 is there anyone else here
that wants to speak on that bill
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
minutes
e
open up an executive session on House
Bill 5
93 and I recognize representative
mcfallen for motion
thank you Mr chairman I move in
expedient to legislate is there a second
I'll second that representative trip
seconds you want to speak to your
motion certainly um let me just pish the
paper out
here it seems to me that while there is
some laudable intent uh in the sponsors
bill the bill is written in such a
fashion as to uh be unworkable uh and uh
even simple things including uh the lack
of definition of a pet the lack of
specification of whether or not the loss
of Consortium only applies to the owner
of the pet uh or to other parties um the
lack of distinction between an
intentional death that was with the
owner's instruction or intent uh versus
an intentional death by a third party
without the owner's instruction or
intent and so on and so forth and I
think we've heard strong testimony from
the um American Kennel Club and dog
owners of the Granite State against it
as well thank you representative trip do
you want to speak to you a
second uh I remember this bill from last
term uh it's uh it's well-intentioned
but I think it has uh unintended
consequences that uh make it uh uh
unable unable to
uh
pass any other discussion on the bill
representative Manos thank you um I
support the itl but I did want to
comment that I greatly appreciated um
the remarks
about at one point in time women were
recognized as being property or chatt of
their husbands or
fathers and the concept of ownership of
pets may be changing over time so I
agree with the itl but I did appreciate
those comments thank you Mr thank you
any other conversation about it seeing
none I asked the cl to call and
roll representative trip
yes clerk votes
yes representative McFarland yes
representative Morton yes representative
Smith yes representative
Horgan
yes representative Paige yes
representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Rambo
yes and chairman Manion
yes 11 yays zero Nays with that I'll
close the executive session on oh wait a
consent will you write a report on that
and with that we're going to close the
e
order and open up the hearing on House
Bill 61 4 and recognize representative
cordelli uh the prime sponsor to
introduce the Bill thank you very much
uh it's it's a pleasure to be in
judiciary today uh for the record Glenn
cordelli representing Tuftonboro molten
Boro
and excuse me Tuftonboro wolfboro and
oapi in the beautiful Lakes
Region um thank you very much for
hearing uh House Bill
614 Abraham Lincoln once said don't
interfere with anything in the
Constitution that must be maintained for
it is the only Safeguard of our
liberties uh I believe the same holds
true for our New Hampshire
Constitution but what happens if your
constitutional rights are
violated what happens if your freedom of
speech is
violated uh a year ago there was a local
freedom of speech uh case that uh caught
my attention and I view it as a freedom
of speech case um this case involved an
exitor high school student uh a freshman
uh on the football team who was on the
school bus and mentioned to his friends
that uh he believed that there were only
two
genders another student overheard the
conversation and argued the point and
even later texted that student um who
had made the original comment and a
brief argument EXC uh excuse me
ensued the next day that student who had
overheard the uh comment contacted the
athletic director and accused The
Freshman of I quote transphobic
bullying the principal and the ad were
contacted and decided the Freshman
should be suspended from the football
team for a period of time
based on this
bullying the suspended freshman filed
suit in Rockingham Superior
Court in court the school officials
argued that he was suspended for
bullying and inappropriate language in
the text
conversation the judge as you'll see in
some of the Articles uh did not buy
their
position and found them and I
quote but
he he found for the uh
school and the reason is in this quote
which is from one of the
Articles because New Hampshire law does
not recognize a private cause of action
for a political subdivision of a
plaintiff's State constitutional rights
in the absence of bodily injury property
damage personal injury or statute the
court grants judgment to the
defendants that's the quote of the judge
from his
ruling so the Freshman walked out of
court with the court finding his favor
but the law was against
him that's what called on me to file
this
legislation as the judge found he was
suspended from the football team due to
his beliefs and comments freedom of
speech there was not a bodily image a
bodily damage um or anything like that
involved in the case so the law did not
provide any remedy for him this was a
case of
speech this simple legislation provides
for any complete violation of a person's
confident confidential rights
constitutional rights excuse me the
court shall provide relief as indicated
in Roman 1 in the um in the uh
legislation beginning on lines on line
nine and this is to be provided even if
monetary damages are not alleged as in
the exer
case I think that this is important
legislation
because we need to defend our
constitutional rights
and it's I don't think it's sufficient
to say you only have a remedy for a
violation of your rights if there's uh
bodily damage or
monetary um issues involved with the uh
with the case um such as a freedom of
speech case so
um I would hope that you would think
about the
quote that I began with with Abraham
Lincoln and
the requirement that we protect our
constitutional rights and our liberties
and um find favorably on this
legislation and I thank you very much
for your
time are there any
questions representative
McFarland I'm sympathetic to the
testimony um I'm not a lawyer though and
so I I would appreciate
clarification of what is intended by
14 um I believe that there is a lawyer
um in the audience who was submitted a
card and I think uh he would have a
better answer for you than I thank you
rep I am not a lawyer
either any other questions
seeing none thank you thank you very
much I only have one card so if you if
somebody else wants to speak they can
fill out a pink card Sarah Burke Cohen
you have a pink card yet no yeah just
then okay all right if you want to if
you want to sit down and you can fill it
out afterwards and then you maybe help
answer that question and then we'll go
can Ian huitt attorney for Cornerstone
and support of House Bill
614 uh this bill now full disclosure by
the way I should say at the outset I'm
litigating the exitor case that
representative cordelli spoke about so I
was obviously happy when he told me he
wanted to introduce this legislation but
the topic that's being addressed by this
bill is much much broader than anything
that was raised in my case including
gender or even Free Speech the problem
that this bill addresses is that all
everyone agrees all courts have held in
New Hampshire under our state
constitution if your rights are being
violated on an ongoing basis or there's
a threatened future violation of your
rights everyone agrees you have a right
to relief under our state constitution
and our state courts even if you just
ignore the Federal Constitution but if
there's a completed violation of your
rights in the past past no New Hampshire
Court has ever held that you have a
right to any remedy whatsoever even a
nominal damages award for that violation
if it's a retrospective violation you
have no right to any retrospective
remedy not even nominal damages not even
declaratory damages the court can't even
say you win and you get nothing no right
to relief so when representative
cordelli told me he wanted to introduce
this bill to address this I was excited
about it um but I will say that I
definitely don't see this bill as any
kind of rebuke to judge Schulman's
decision the trial court judge in this
case I think he's a great jurist
actually um the opinion was largely
favorable and judge Schulman was right
to say no New Hampshire Court has ever
held that if you bring a New Hampshire
constitutional suit you have a right to
retrospective relief now that's all
rights that's not just free speech
that's free speech right to bear arms
right to freedom of the press any right
if it's in the past you're not going to
get relief unless you go into federal
court under the Federal Constitution
instead of going into our state courts
and this is something that this
legislature can fix if we want people in
New Hampshire to be able to rely on our
state courts and we want New Hampshire
to be independent and we don't want
Granite Staters to have to rely on and
essentially be dictated to by what
federal courts happen to say at that
moment so I actually have a case before
the state supreme sueme court right now
where I have like a 50-page brief that
basically is arguing the New Hampshire
Constitution itself entitles you to
retrospective relief if you look at the
text or the history of the Constitution
but even if I win that it is a good idea
for the general court to have a statute
addressing this just like under federal
constitutional law you can bring a 14th
Amendment suit or if you don't bring a
14th Amendment suit you can bring a
section 1983 suit under a statute that
Congress passed in 1871 and they
basically passed that to back stop our
federal constitutional rights and make
sure you have a remedy in court and that
is what that that is what the
legislature would be doing by passing
this law so regardless of what uh you
may think about what the framers of our
state constitution intended I would say
if you just think about it logically and
from a standpoint of basic fairness it
really just does not make sense it's
kind of a fluke to say you have a right
to Rel if there's a threatened future or
an ongoing violation but if it happened
in the past you have no right to relief
a right is a right you should be
entitled to some sort of Remedy and I
would love to take any questions but one
thing I'll say is really any possible
political objection I can think of to
this bill whether that's uh what about
frivolous suits we have to deal with how
do we deal with the various official
immunity claims my answer to all those
is going to be pretty simple which is
our courts already know exactly how to
deal with all those question questions
under ongoing and prospective claims and
under federal constitutional claims uh
they have an extensive body of case law
that will analyze any one of those
issues that I just raised so just the
last thing I'll note here is that New
Hampshire has the second oldest
continuously existing constitution in
the western world uh after Massachusetts
our constitution goes back to
1784 and when our constitution was being
passed Granite Staters three times
rejected in popular votes the
Constitution that was proposed to them
because it didn't provide the people
enough rights against the government and
the framers kept adding more and more
rights until they had something that the
people of New Hampshire were satisfied
with our constitution takes as its model
John Adams original Massachusetts
Constitution but if you compare the two
if you look at our Constitution and you
look at massachusetts's you'll find
Massachusetts is just sounds relatively
weak it's got the same rights but our
framers put a lot more kind of fanatical
emphasis on those rights because they
wanted to emphasize the government would
be restrained the people have strong
rights and we want to assure you granted
Staters of that so that you'll approve
this constitution so I would say it
especially doesn't make any sense in New
Hampshire that we have this kind of
historical fluke and oversight where if
a violation is in the past uh you have
no right to relief so I'd be happy to
take any questions about
anything representative
McFarland thank you Mr chairman I I'll
just reiterate my prior question with a
little bit more specificity so if I
understand you correctly um you're
you're asserting in par in section two
in in Rose 12 to 14 here um to the
extent that you agree with the language
you're asserting that um you already had
this remedy under the Constitution and
that this is also now being granted in
this statute um and you already had this
remedy in common law and if I'm right
about that could you also please clarify
uh how this would affect the ability to
petition for address of grievances to
the general
court representative I think you have a
pretty comprehensive understanding of
the issues I would just add one thing to
what you said yes that is part of why
section two is worded this way but also
our constitutional law in New Hampshire
has a weird fluke um separate from what
I've just talked about that is not found
in other states where when you bring an
article 14 claim our state supreme court
actually I don't think anyone else does
this in the country some kind of
constitutional claims when the court is
deciding whether you have relief under
the state constitution they actually
will look to State statutes to decide
whether you have
constitutional relief so this isn't just
kind of a way to say you know we
disclaim the idea you don't have a
constitutional remedy it actually also
could affect the outcome of cases the
last example of this most recently was
cater k a t r that was in 2010 and
basically what happens is the court says
if we we we will grant to you a
constitutional remedy under article 14
in this quasy Equitable way if the
general court is not granted you statute
and the second part of your question I I
don't see the only way in which it would
um you know bring there could be a case
that addressed the right to petition the
general court is I mean the only thing I
can think of I'm just thinking on my
feet here in spitballing if let's say
you uh your right to petition was denied
for a long time and then the general
court eventually granted your right to
petition and so then maybe your
prospective claim is moot but you say
hey but they unconstitutionally denied
my right to petition for a year so you
don't have any prospective claim anymore
but let's say you say I still want
nominal damages or at least declare that
what they did was unconstitutional right
now that that retrospective claim you
don't have because our courts would say
retrospective constitutional rights
claims no remedy but now you would have
one under this Bill thank you yeah any
other questions representative tur yeah
thanks thanks for taking the question
I'm wondering and I do not know this
area of the law particularly well um is
the difference between the uh future or
current uh situation of having your
rights violated uh versus what's being
discussed in this bill the idea that
primarily that would be and maybe I'm
misusing the term sort of injunctive
relief which says
the Court's going to stop your rights
from being violated whereas this seems
to be awarding damages in a very
different
circumstance that is right except that
our courts have been very clear that
they've never as I think judge Schulman
accurately said in his opinion there has
never been any case in New Hampshire
that says you have any retrospective uh
right to relief so this bill kind of
pointedly doesn't even really take up
directly the monetary damages question
and basically just says look you've got
some sort of right to relief could be
nominal could be declaratory could be
some other Equitable relief but you're
right you have you have prospective
injunctive relief if your constitutional
rights are going to be violated in the
future but if they've been violated in
the past right now not only can you not
get monetary damages you can't get
anything under the state constitution
the um I should address the quote
representative cordelli open with from
Judge Schulman's opinion the reason that
judge Schulman spoke about bodily injury
and things like that is you could bring
a tort claim against a subdivision or
against the state um so if police
officer beats you up illegally let's say
you might bring a toric claim for bodily
injury but you could not bring you
couldn't say that police officer
violated my state constitutional rights
under a b or c provision of our state
constitution you would just have to rely
on on Tor law or you could under the
Federal Constitution go into federal
court but people really should be able
to remedy these claims in our state
court
thank you any other
questions representative
Manus thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm I'm really
not clear on what specific remedy it is
that you're seeking by way of this
statute that I get the nominal damages
but isn't a judge going to say whatever
the situation is aside from exitor
um somebody's State constitutional rats
were violated the judge has to say that
otherwise there can't be any conclusion
to the case there can't be a judgment so
just the acknowledgement that somebody's
rights were
violated is in
fact um the
remedy you you raise a really good point
actually and and in Old nominal damages
cases from like the early 19th century
justice story on the US Supreme Court
said the idea that you can say someone's
legal rights were violated but they have
no remedy whatsoever not even nominal
damages that doesn't even make sense he
argued you're just uh it's incoherent
because if there is no remedy we would
typically say that really isn't a legal
right maybe the government did something
immoral but they didn't violate your
legal rights if you have no remedy in
this case I mean this is kind of an
illustration of of your question the
judge said um you it seems like under
the facts here that your rights were
violated that the school lied Etc but
regardless of any of that you lose
because it's a
retrospective claim so we we don't even
have the right really to declaratory
judgment we don't have the right to have
the court say you win as long as it's a
retrospective claim um the three kinds
of remedies that are mentioned in in
here are as you mentioned nominal
damages declaratory relief and one thing
I'll comment on that I I am in you're
aware of based on your question is with
respect to the other Equitable relief
Clause already actually our state
Supreme Courts under just general court
statutes are courts of equity so that
other Equitable relief clause in some
ways is just kind of rearticulating the
Equitable jurisdiction our state
Superior Courts already have so you
could interpret this bill as kind of
just
saying you know the minimal possible
relief that could remedy a retrospective
violation that's the relief you have
yeah follow up thank you
um but there would have been a judgment
entered in this case correct and it
would have said a violated B's rights
and isn't the person or the entity that
violated that person's rights put on
notice not to repeat the behavior and of
course if they do then you can get
declaratory relief and injunctive relief
Etc for prospective Behavior or future
Behavior well they did win um you know
the end of the opinion says that they
won and the you know statements from the
school in my case for example have been
you know we disagree with the judge
saying our clients all lied but we're
glad we won and and they are right they
did win um and I would say you know
setting aside the facts of my case in my
appeal um my appeal is just on the
question presented of does the New
Hampshire Constitution afford
retrospective relief for completed
violations so we're not talking about
gender or what the Free Speech test is
or any of that stuff because the judge
really kind of decided all that stuff in
our favor so um regardless of what you
think about the judge's opinion in my
case under any future case in the
absence of something like this and or uh
Supreme Court decision in my favor the
Court's going to say anyone whose State
constitutional rights were violated you
remedy could I just ask yes go
ahead me would you be willing to provide
us and redacting if if there are minors
involved in the case uh would you be
willing to provide us with a copy of the
Court's opinion absolutely I'd be
willing to provide you any documents and
they are already all redacted so that'd
be very easy thank you representative
any other questions seeing none thank
you thank
good afternoon my name is Sarah Burke
Cohen I represent the New Hampshire
Municipal Association the New Hampshire
Municipal Association opposes this bill
it is vague and overly broad this bill
would allow plaintiffs to layer
constitutional claims on top of existing
statutory claims for which they already
have a
remedy currently a violation of the
State Constitution will in almost all
cases also be a violation of the Federal
Constitution so there is already a cause
of action under 42 USC section
1983 in the few instances where the
state constitution provides broader
rights than the federal constition There
is almost certainly a state statute that
already provides a remedy in short there
are very few if any gaps where someone
whose State constitutional rights are
violated would not already have a claim
under either federal or state law this
bill would allow zoning appeals tax
appeals right to no complaints and many
other claims to be refra excuse me
reframed as constitutional torts for
those who think I'm being an alarmist
please understand that lawyers have
already tried in cases to do this
um in one such case in 1986 the New
Hampshire Supreme Court rejected the
effort to turn a local Road dispute into
a constitutional claim in that claim
Justice sudor wrote as follows we fear
that um provision of supplemental cause
of action to provide an additional
remedy in these circumstances would
inevitably lead to the conversion of
every road dispute in a constitutional
Tor action which would carry a right to
a jury trial separate from from the
layout of appeal the likely
multiplication of litigation resulting
from a squabble would be too high a
price to pay for such supplemental cause
of
action in some this bill would open up
the 43 articles of part one of the New
Hampshire Constitution and 101 articles
in part two of the New Hampshire
Constitution and allow allow layering of
these constitutional claims on top of
existing claims which already have a
remedy and create runaway litigation
that would increase property taxes due
to significantly increased legal extense
for for cities and towns therefore uh
nhma opposes this bill and I'm open to
questions any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you is there anyone else that wants to
speak on House Bill 614 that hasn't
turned the pink card in seeing none I'm
going to close the hearing on house
bills
614 and that concludes our
business thus far I don't know if we
want to discuss any more possible
but 762 is an early Bill and that is the
$30,000 to the judicial branch for the
yep
e
okay we're going to open up an executive
session on house Bill
746 and I recognize representative Smith
to make a motion uh yes Mr chair um I
second representative turer you want to
speak to your motion um I would um this
bill was originally assigned to
Municipal and County and then
transferred to
Judiciary um it was in the calendar with
appropriate notice um there was no
sponsor either prime or other sponsor
who appeared um a member of the
committee out of courtesy introduced the
bill um there were no witnesses there
was no written material um submitted uh
to the committee and therefore the
responsible thing I believe for the
committee to do is to it the bill
representative TR you want to speak to
you a second no any other discussion on
the
bill seeing none I'll ask the clct to
call a
yes CLK votes yes representative
McFarland yes representative Morton yes
representative Smith
yes representative Paige yes
representative Manos yes representative
tur yes representative Rambo yes and
chairman Manion
nay okay and I don't know if that's Mr
chair I assume this will go on um
consent yes no objection to that
none
and I will write the report thank you I
really write the but I'll refer to it as
a all right I think that's uh I'll close
the hearing the executive session on
House Bill
746 and if there's no other business I
don't know if there's anything else we
can get done
but if you want to re Jour at this
point feel satisfi just like to point
out to the committee
sh we will meet again as a committee
next
Wednesday I would urge everyone
to look at the bills that are on the
Wednesday I know I'm entertaining but I
entertaining um they
are they are important
bills um I leave to you to decide if
that means that they are important to
pass or important to defeat but I I
really urge you to come
prepared um and I think you will see
what I mean when you look at the bills
if you haven't yet had a chance to do
so thank you I
agree okay if there's nothing else uh
we're